- Now survival is just,
the rules have changed man.
It used to being a Sigma male man.
Now it's hard, now you gotta pay bills.
Fuck man
- I can't be a Sigma male
while I pay the bills,
fuck that shit.
- Fuck Sigma male,
don't pay your bills, number 1.
(bright intro music)
- Hi everyone.
Welcome to another episode
of the Trash Taste podcast.
I'm Joey and I'm with the boys.
- Hello.
- Was that the intro?
Man intro, Joey intros
have really gone down hill
in the past year man,
maybe like salty salmon spices
or whatever the fuck you started.
- What are you? The
fucking YouTube comments?
(all laugh)
- I like the old intros better.
I like the old studio better.
- I remember when Joey put
effort into his intros.
- I'm Joey. You're enjoying
(indistinct) on Trash Taste.
- I remember when like half of my intros
would get the episodes demonetized.
- Yeah. So annoying. We lost
like thousands of dollars.
Cause Joey's one of those,
couldn't resist being Australian.
- Cause Joey was just being Australian.
- Yeah. I can't help them.
I have to fight the odds
to say all the bad words.
- Can you guys tell I'm
absolutely ripped today.
I went to the gym the
first time in two months.
- I was about, Oh my, what!
- I'm absolutely pumped today.
- First time in two months?
- First time in two
months, my body is dying.
- So you signed up to the
new gym at your new place?
- I did. I did.
And it's different, and the
etiquette is slightly different.
So it kind of threw me off.
- Wait, did you sign up by yourself?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Impossible.
- I don't believe you.
I don't believe you.
- I was trying to remember how I did it
and it was confusing because he was,
- It was all a blur.
- He was asking things, I was like, yes.
- Well that's just
every interaction I have
with a Japanese person in Japan.
They ask me something and I just say yes.
- So here's how good my Japanese
has gotten to this point now.
It's kind of like,
I'm kind of filling in the blanks.
It kind of feels like
you're doing one of those
Mario Party mini games
where you see a part of the
sequence and you're like,
I think I know where
this sequence is going.
- It's like going into Mario Party game
without looking at the controls, right?
Say, I think, I think
this is out of the box.
- Yeah. So now I'm
getting to the point where
I'm accustomed to the normal
flow of signing up to things.
So I kind of understand
what they're saying
and I understood most
of what was told of me.
And a lot of it was just like,
Hey, read this. And I'm
like, Oh, soon. Soon.
- It's just really weird when
they pulled the knife out.
Maybe started selling my blog,
I guess that's tradition.
- The rectal exam was
a bit weird, you know.
- It's a little longer, but it's so,
- So did the signing up take
as long as the original stuff?
- No, no, no.
But, I signed up to Anytime Fitness.
- Oh, Anytime Fitness.
- Okay. Yeah
- American chain, I'm pretty sure.
- Is it?
I don't know. Could we fact check that.
- Go fact check that.
But listen, when I went in
there it looked American.
- Because all the gyms,
usually white people
to advertise their gym
- Yeah. They do.
At the front of our old
gym, there was like,
it was like five banners
of just like really attractive white guys.
- I've never seen a Japanese
person be advertised
on a gym before in Japan.
- It was weird how in Japanese gyms
it is just white people is
like the standard, I'm like
- I think it might just be
because like going to the gym
in this country is like a fucking luxury
because of how expensive that shit is.
- It's not just that, who the fuck,
what Japanese person
has time to go to a gym.
- That's true.
- Also most of the Japanese
people are in shape, right?
And the, and the people
that aren't in shape.
I don't think they care
about being in shape.
They have like,
they're like, I've got
everything I need in my life
I don't need to be in shape.
I've got my seven lessons.
- So why are you working out?
Honestly, you're just
like naturally in shape.
Fuck you.
- How did you get fat?
How did that happen?
Basically?
- Yeah. Pretty much.
Yeah. I signed up and I dunno.
I mean, I'm pretty.
Yeah. Like I said,
I'm pretty sure I had
time for this is American.
We had a fact check
and it wasn't American.
I shouldn't, it was America.
That sounds American. Like joy fits 24.
Yeah. That it does not American.
Yeah. That sounds Japanese.
That sounds like what a
Japanese people think.
American people think that
yes, you're joyful in.
- Your fears and it's open 24.
- Hours. So it's a joint.
I mean,
anytime fitness is much
better than I signed up to it.
It didn't really know
what the was going on.
They took my picture. I got the key thing.
I signed my life away.
They asked for my card.
Yeah. It worked out.
So I believe I'm signed
up. So that's good.
I walked in yesterday
and nobody stopped me.
- One thing I've noticed about
moving is like, you know,
having to cancel memberships
and having to cancel stuff is
like 10 times easier than signing
up to something, which is.
- Not it's the opposite
in the west, right?
- Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah.
Cause like I was dreading having
to cancel my gym membership
because I remember when we
signed up to a gym membership,
it took like 45 minutes to an
hour of just reading forms.
So I was just like, so me and Cindy,
you had to go cancel a gym
membership. And we said one word,
which was like, we would
like to cancel a membership.
And we had to sign one piece
of paper, took five minutes.
Why can't signing up? Be that easy.
- No leaving fees. Just like, yeah.
Use the gym until at the end of.
- It's like everything you'll not suppose
to do as a business.
Right. It's like why?
It's like, I love how,
how hesitant they are to sign
you up to shoot. It's like,
are you sure you want to give
us money every month? Yeah.
That's why I'm here. It's just
let me in for Christ sake.
Exactly. The moment you leave.
They're like, oh, thank God.
He got to take it and get the out.
- Like I have to change
over my internet as well.
And that was surprisingly
painless. Cause they were like,
no worries.
Did you want to cancel your
incident or did you want to move
to a new place? And I'm just like,
it's it is which one's easier.
And I'm like, it's the same.
It's just what exactly.
It's like, where's the catch?
Where's the cat.
- Why is it like,
so it's like pulling teeth
when you're like signing out
fully water or gas up in new places. Like,
are you sure you want water
in your place? It's like, yes,
please. Thank you.
Like I only just, okay.
So I moved to our current
place, like what five?
Almost six months ago. Right.
And I only just finished
finalizing by water stuff.
What really? Yeah.
Because like for some reason,
cause I got like a new bank
account and with the Cayman new
card and for some reason they
didn't allow me to use my new
bank account because it's not
under the same name or some
kind of, well, you said, you
said the B word bank in Japan.
But I've done it before
at my previous place.
And it was pretty painless. Right.
So I was like, okay.
I mean, you know, it's
just changing a bank.
How hard could it be
famous? Last question.
I could have been nothing
with the word bank in Japan is
ever easy, but what I
don't understand, right.
Is that okay? So I signed
up and I'm like, okay,
I want to change to my new
bank because like, you know,
my money situation has
changed at this new place.
And they were like, sure, no worries.
We'll send you a form.
You can fill out all your
information and then mail it back
to us. I'm like, yeah.
All right. Email was also a thing.
But anyway, so there's,
so I think about a month after
that phone call, finally,
the phone comes in. I was like, all right.
I don't know why this
took a month to send out,
but she'll fill it in
five minutes, send it off.
Two months later, I get a
phone call and they say, ah,
so your bank is not able
to be used on my door.
And I'm like, Chateau, Marty.
You could have told me that
on the phone three months ago.
Why is it now after all this
like waiting and sending out a
form that you'll finally like.
- We're going to call you up
and be like, yeah, by the way,
the rate of inflation has
changed significantly.
In the past two months, we
do details all over again.
- Have you been paying
for water since then?
So before it just used to
be like a bank transfer,
like every month automatically.
But since then I've had
to like get the form.
They mail you the form
that says the amount.
And then I have to go to the
family mod or the company
nearby and do it cash. Yeah.
Which just like me up because
sometimes I don't check my
mail every day.
And then there was one month
where I almost like got my
water stopped. Oh my God.
Because they just straight
up, didn't send me my form.
And I'm like, and then they
call me and they're like, oh,
so you haven't paid for
your thing. I'm like,
I haven't give me the floor.
What am I supposed to do?
Am I supposed to be like,
am I supposed to go and go to the light?
Am I supposed to go to the
company being like, ah,
so I don't have the
form, but like, trust me.
I know you guys. I have to pay.
- I've realized right when I
first moved here, I thought,
oh my God, I can pay my
bills at the local company.
Amazing. This is great.
Yeah, no, I realize it's
just to avoid banks.
Yeah. It's just like this whole cut.
This country has set up a system
where the banks just don't
need to do anything,
but they still got to have all your money.
- And they give you like,
what is it like 0.0,
zero 1% interest assumption.
- The interest gets wiped out by every,
every time you want to take out money.
- Like you, you basically,
there's less interest in the P the,
the fees you pay for like any service.
Japan is the only country where
like hiding your money under
your mattress might be a better
investment than putting it
into a bank. Honestly, it's
probably safe for this.
- And spend money with a country
that people just don't know.
It's like, why would we give you interest?
If people are going to keep
money in that bank? What the.
- Weirdly is like a weed,
like money saving
mentality in this country,
even for who have the money to.
- Spend. So yeah, apparently the,
one of the reasons why they
didn't want to give more money
out to people during the
pandemic is because we just don't
spend the money.
So they would just be giving
money that wouldn't help
stimulate the economy because
people wouldn't go up.
Even if you gave them a thousand bucks,
most people were just
going to keep it going to.
- Oh, it does not surprise me
because like domestic tourism is
massive here. It's just a massive.
- But.
- It's like 90% of the economy.
- But it's like,
from what I understand of
the domestic tourism here,
it is like a massive luxury.
Most people can't afford to
go from what I understand.
And also don't have the time.
- Yeah.
I think the biggest resource
for any Japanese person,
especially working is
time. How'd you have.
- To do anything. If you
have go to Rio can, right?
If you stay there for two nights,
I guarantee you're probably
like one out of 100 people who
are staying there for more than one night.
Everyone leaves the next day.
Always I've noticed that,
like, if I go and park my
car, it's full next day,
empty the car park at like two o'clock.
Cause no one's checking until like fall.
And I'm the only who apparently stayed.
Even though it makes more
sense to have a hotel room for
these two days,
because you at least get
one full day of the room.
- Yeah. That,
that never made sense to me
because how can you enjoy the
day?
Because that means you spend
most Rio can't and you can't
check until three minutes,
all three or four and they
weren't there you check in
earlier as well.
This space,
even if their space with
Japanese hotels and it's not just
Rio Cannes it's hotels as well.
Even if they have space in the hotel,
you still can't check in
until the check in time.
- You'll have the problem though.
Is that like the main demographic
that goes to dual cons for
one night is usually like retirees, right?
And to them, the con itself is the.
- Right.
But you know what sucks is the
fact that you don't even get
like a full 24 hours when you buy one.
Now that's why in my head
I'm like, so in efficient,
like you should never ever,
like, even if you stay in, like,
let's say you're staying in Kyoto. Right?
You shouldn't,
you should never change hotel
every night because you're
just wasting time wasting,
wasting time that you could
have in the hotel room. Yeah.
You get the breakfast as well
or whatever. I don't know.
You count your backgrounds
to pain in the. Yeah.
- Yeah. Plus plus like
when I'm on holiday,
when I'm staying in a hotel or Rio camp,
what I want to relax,
I don't want to think about
what time I need to wake up the
morning after that's true.
I want at least one
day when I'm just like,
if I want to lie in, I can lie in.
I want to crack some
beers open with the boys.
I want to know me. They be
lying until like 10 o'clock,
you know, whatever.
But in Rio cans you have to
wake up at aides because most
people are only staying there
for one night. And you know,
they, they have to wake
up early to check out.
- It's all on Japan side of
things like having to sleep or
getting to sleep in is
like the privilege way.
- I mean,
you would stay here for more
than one night without you
privileged.
- I, there was when I went to
Rio con I went to one and I
remember I was just, I loved it.
But then I was absolutely
appalled that they made us check
out at 9:00 AM. Yeah.
I was really privileged.
I don't know if this is my privilege.
Like I'm 9:00 AM not 9:00 AM
broken me a chance to like
brush my teeth and wake up.
- At night.
You have to check out a non am.
And I guarantee like earliest
check-in is like, for.
- Thing. It's like, what are
you cleaning for so long?
Well, not surely this
cannot take that long.
The one thing that I love about
like American hotels is that
whenever I've always
asked for late checkout,
or they've always given it to me, like,
if it's just like an hour extra,
like the always chill about it,
like sometimes they made me
they've charged me like 20,
30 bucks extra, but Japanese hotel.
I remember one time I sit in a
hotel room in Niigata and the
hotel room itself was $90
for an extra hour. Right.
Was $70 just for one extra
hours to stay in the room past
11. Right.
And I was like, whoa.
I was like, did I hear that?
Correct? Can you, can you say that again?
My once you don't blink
like 70, the room was 90.
How does that make any
sense? Tell me like sit down.
- 'Cause I think to them,
anything past that time limit
is an extra day to them.
That offering late checkout
without offering late checkout.
You know what I mean? Like it's
like, we got late checkout,
but it's not really late
checkout, but it is late checkout.
Like.
- Sometimes empty as well.
It was like Pete Corona.
There was nobody staying here.
Why don't you trying to swindle me?
- They're fighting for their life, man.
They need that extra money.
They're like, oh, let's try this guy.
- I'll give you I'll. I know, I know.
It's not culture. I'll tip you, man.
Just leave me alone. Don't
charge me 70 bucks for this.
What do I need to do?
Who do I need to stop?
- It's weird though.
Because like most like high-end
dual cons, especially they,
they usually quiet, lenient
with a late checkout and stuff.
Like we just,
myself and AKI and a few
others just came back from this
deal in Yamanashi. And like they said,
the checkout was like nine 30,
but we were there to like 11
and then we'll like, yeah,
you're good.
It's like, okay.
Then why you kicking us out at nine 30?
If that's the case count,
did you ask them for late
checkout or were they just like,
no, no.
They said the night before
they were like, oh yeah.
So it's nine 30 check out. Is that okay?
And we were like, we
might be here for longer.
Is that okay? And then we're like, okay.
I'm like,
then why did you tell me
that was the checkout time?
Like maybe just most Japanese
people just don't ask most of
these people. Like those are the rules.
We must follow.
- Really anal about getting
there. If it says 12,
they are so paranoid about
checking out after like one
minute after 12.
- That's just like Japanese
culture in general though.
Like we're very strict on
time. Like every time was,
nobody has.
- Tell us. It's like,
I don't want to be like
fighting for my life.
10 minutes for checkout.
Like, oh, I'll come,
I'll come 20 minutes after.
No one's going to care.
No one knows no one has ever cared, man.
I'm, I'm trying to enjoy this bathtub.
You gave me, you know what I mean?
Come on.
- It's like, how can, how
can you enjoy it when.
- You're stressed about time?
And I guess that's why I'm so
confused as to why people stay
in VO cans for like one night,
because I feel like you need
a minimum of two nights to
enjoy the experience three nights.
If you really just want a
relaxing weekend or whatever,
that's, that's, that's
real privilege in Japan.
Yeah.
- Like I'd never heard of,
anyone's like a Japanese postal
staying at a dual con for
more than one night
because to them it's like,
because to them that one night
is probably the equivalent to
like a week to something
it's like, oh my God,
finally a night where I'm not
working and just get to like,
do whatever the I want.
- Nothing about your cons
is that there's like,
they really pressure
you to go to breakfast.
And I'm already a breakfast
guy and especially not a real
con breakfast sky, you know?
Like I don't need a
three-course meal for breakfast,
which is basically what those
breakfast is. Are what's an.
- American breakfast thing.
- They're big.
- Breakfast makes American
breakfast looked time.
- Yeah. Death by a thousand bites, bro.
Like they just F they keep
giving you tiny pieces and they
keep coming and they
keep, and they won't stop.
I, you know, you know, it's
over when they finally asked,
like, do you want some tea or coffee?
But by that point you're already dead.
They've already stuffed you stuff.
- I actually feel bad when
everyone got mad at you about the
breakfast tweet and your, and your hotel.
Because it was, it was like
one of the few times I'm like,
I agree with corner.
I'm just like, yeah.
Yeah. I, you don't need that
much for you for breakfast.
- You really know.
- I just, you know, I'm, I'm a,
I'm a simple man for breakfast.
I don't really eat it.
I tend to eat it. If I've got
something big about to happen,
like the cycling special. All right.
Yeah. I'll have some breakfast,
cause that's just a
wise choice to exercise.
But if I'm not exercising,
I'm not eating breakfast.
Yeah. Give me a cereal bar at most.
Right. I'm I'm I'm not really big on it.
I'd rather have a nicer lunch. Yeah.
- I'm not hungry when I wake up. No,
not all people can just
wake up and go like, yeah.
I feel like a buffet.
- Yeah, no, because like,
if I have a big breakfast,
which I've really enjoyed
the big breakfast,
cause I'm not hungry for breakfast.
Like that means I'm just
not going to eat lunch.
Or that means I'm going to
get hungry for dinner at this
really weird time, which is
like a bit early for dinner,
but like too late for lunch. Right.
It's like up my eating schedule.
- The most as being,
you know, when you like,
you kind of hungry when you wake up,
maybe you didn't eat too
much the night before. Yeah.
But then like, it really,
really starts to get hungry at like 11.
That's the worst time. Cause you're like,
it's too early for lunch,
but I'm holding out.
But I don't want breakfast,
breakfast, but I'm,
I'm holding out here. I got them life.
I know all my.
- I just, I think, I think
what it is is that I,
I hate the feeling of like
having a food coma before
12:00 PM.
It's like,
cause you're just tired in
the morning and I'm like,
I don't want that.
- Down. A bunch of water when you wake up.
Yes. I mean, I'm normally
full from that as well.
I.
- Drink, I drink a lot of water.
You drink.
- Water a lot more just.
- In general. I do that.
I don't see why that's
unhealthy hydro home.
- Probably probably didn't
like 500 milliliters of water.
- I drink at least like
minimum two or three cups.
- So just want to get
stuck in with my day.
Like if I need a shower, I do that.
I go start working. I just kinda wanna,
I kinda want to get on
with my day. I dunno.
I don't really want to sit around.
- Yeah. Like huffing having like a fry up.
That that means something
that means it's like a special
occasion. You know?
It's like, I can't have a fry up everyday.
I don't even recommend you
have a fry every everyday.
But like even, Even just
cereal to me is just,
that's a big meal for breakfast to me.
Like a lot of people say
breakfast is the most important
meal of the day.
I don't know how accurate.
- Oh, that's the cereal companies.
The cereal companies have.
Crikey does making us think
that these carbon monstrosities
on necessary. I do not need cornflakes.
And I wake up.
- The most I'll eat for
breakfast is single bananas.
I'll have this.
- There were chemicals in the
cornflakes to turn your gay
something on the frogs game.
Rusty's.
- Like the most I'll have for
breakfast is like a banana.
And that's like.
- Yeah, the fruit companies,
aren't trying to convince me to
big fruit companies though.
Cause it's like the whole, the
whole, you know, the whole,
the whole chart came from the
pyramid of what you should eat
and your day and you should eat this much.
And it's just complete nonsense
pyramid scheme. Well, yeah.
And like the whole idea of that,
you need to eat these corn flakes,
which offers no nutritional
value in the morning and stuff.
- Like that. Like the bottom, right?
- It's like, no, it was all
pioneered by these, you know,
companies,
but way back that I had an
agenda to promote their stuff.
Yeah. And of course, if, if,
if you're the Kellogg's team,
you're gonna have your scientific
research team. Of course,
you're going to be like, Hey,
Kellogg's scientific team.
Could you maybe, maybe not.
I'm not looking to have,
excuse me, results.
But like if there was some kind
of correlation that said the
calyx was good for breakfast,
really help us out again.
- I'm not saying you should
convince the world that fruit
loops is healthy or anything,
but maybe like a hint at the same.
- Like
That contract for five years
is not going to be necessary.
No, one's buying cornflakes.
So yeah.
I, I,
I didn't know what age I just
was like no more cereal for
me. I won't do it.
I didn't really ever eat cereal.
- I wasn't, I wasn't brought
up in a cereal household,
so I never got the craving of
it. And then a toast house,
not like cereal to me
always tasted like a sweet,
like a dessert. Right?
You go.
- I will say.
And I've just shat on cereal
for like five minutes.
I do like brand flakes. I
really realized I love bread.
But like I remember one
time, one time as a kid,
when I discovered bran flakes,
I thought these are so good
that I just will keep eating
them all day.
So I had the whole box in one
day and that was me and Coco
puffs. Yeah.
And.
- Bran flakes is like.
- On crack, like, oh Lord,
my toilet activity that day.
I was, I imagined they had the,
they were filming Lord of the rings,
mortar scenes out of my bathroom.
Then that time it was
horrible. I was so much.
- Pain. There's nothing
worse than an overly fiber.
Oh my.
- God. I was, I was scared.
I was genuinely scared.
I was like 12 years old.
And I was like, why do they
make them taste so good?
Yeah.
- So I'm like, oh I, yeah.
I used to have a horrible
diet when I was a little kid.
Like.
- But everyone does, your
parents are like, yes, go on it.
Those gummies that were
made in the ninja turtles.
- Yeah. Cause like, cause like my,
my parents had no retaliation
on giving me my sister,
like Coco puffs and like fruit
loops and like MuTu grain and
all the like sugary off cereals.
- And you know, now when
you're a parent, that it's, it,
it seems very difficult
because you're already kind of
struggling just to just get by.
The last thing you want to do
is start like comparing cocoa
puffs with, you know, it,
it shuts the kid out for 10 minutes,
give them the cocoa pops. Right.
But then later on you're like, all right,
maybe I shouldn't have gave
him given that a kid's four
slices of Nutella bread,
maybe 50 grams of sugar for breakfast.
- I feel like it was a
blessing that I didn't like,
I didn't discover the teller
until like I wasn't, oh my God.
If I discovered the teller as a kid,
which a lot of people did,
I like my diet would have been destroyed.
- My diet was destroyed
because it's like, oh, okay,
you had cargo puffs for breakfast.
And then my mom would pack
Nutella sandwiches for lunch.
And I was just like, how did
I not gain a million pounds?
- Luckily when you're
young, it's much easier.
Thank you.
- Young, young and Asian.
That's like the life
hack right there. Right.
- I despised them.
My mum kept up with what was
healthy because it just meant
that I never got to eat anything fun.
And all the kids around me
always had like under the one
there's one kid. Okay.
And he was a bit overweight,
but he always had chocolate
spread sandwiches.
And I just think that sounds so cool.
I had a little chocolate bread, man.
I'm out here eating my cheese
sandwich, like a peasant,
like a king.
He's getting chocolate spread
with a chocolate yogurt, bro.
I'm like eating even good. But then,
but then when he wasn't eating
his parents unfortunately
set him up to fail.
It was a good when I
tried it, I thought, oh,
this doesn't taste.
Not no chocolate spread.
Doesn't like chocolate
mousse and all that.
I didn't really like that. And.
- I may maybe just because
he wasn't normalized for me.
I hardly had it. So every time
I did have it, I'm just like,
oh, I'm having chocolate for a meal.
This is, this is a lifestyle right here.
This is.
- I love cheese, strings, cheese straight.
- Awesome.
- It's fun. Even now I enjoy doing it.
- I definitely enjoy this process.
- I didn't even like
trying to get it as thin,
as possible as well. And just like.
- Try to get like that. Perfect.
Like it's just like.
- Oh, I dunno if they have this, they.
- Have shoestring satisfying.
- Southeast Asia, two strings.
They don't think they do.
It's just like this. Like.
- It's in all the
imports. Like supermarket.
- It's not real cheese.
I don't know how they do.
I don't know how they get real.
- Cheese, but it tastes better
than real cheese in a sense.
But then it doesn't. But.
- Like it's like cheese flavored plastic.
- It's like playing a
mini game to eat cheese.
And for some reason that
just adds the flavor.
I don't know why.
- Yeah. I used to,
I used to have to do this
thing when I was little.
I know if I'm the only
one, but like I would,
I wouldn't like rip it and
then immediately eat it.
I would kind of rip it and
try and like create a perfect
pile.
- Hannibal Lecter.
- And then I like put it
in a rhino, like my finest.
- My name is Joseph.
I'm 12 years old. I live in Melbourne.
School cafeteria.
- Making perfectly cut off
string cheese, this flying it.
- Oh yeah.
- Never had a cheese missing out.
- You're missing the flavor is. But.
- I feel,
I feel if you're an adult and
you've never had string cheese
as a kid, it's kind of a
toll hurdle to like get.
- Th there are some things that
I try nowadays in Japan and
I'm like, I've never had
a Japanese childhood,
but I feel the childhood in this.
You know what I mean?
- Like.
- Some of the stuff we tried
in the company episodes right.
With with that crisp thing that was like,
that was just like one big it
or whatever and I'm just like,
I've I can feel, I can see
myself eating this as a kid.
- I also have like the
fish cakes, which is vital.
The like, oh,
what the kamaboko maybe
like the fish and cheese.
- Or something.
Yeah. I had both of those
when I was a kid, I was like.
- Bro.
- Just like, just anything
that was like of that size.
I would just try.
- Yeah.
Like I realize there's some
things that if you didn't grow
up with it, oh, you
probably wouldn't enjoy it.
Like in Thailand, in Thailand,
we have this snack called Tato, which is,
which is basically just dried fish.
- Quiet Southeast Asia.
- Which is.
- Just like, what, what is it?
It's it's just like dried fish. Right.
It's just.
- It's like, cause when I think of Tara,
I think it was the purple
a light sweet potato. I.
- Have no interest associated with.
- Yeah. So,
so I remember like eating this
as a kid and thinking this
tastes amazing.
And I brought some back to
England and I gave some to my
mates and they had, they had
a bite and they were like,
this is just fish food. I'm
like this isn't fish food.
Yeah. Yeah.
It's that? It's that, it's that one.
Yeah. Oh yeah.
The fish drinks basically
fishing, like cheese strings,
but we fish.
- The fish and they did this.
- Shrinks out of everything.
- I mean, I just hear that
story and I'm just like, oh,
there's you might as over
here being like first time.
- I've never.
- Got mom every time. Every time I like,
cause I grew up with Vegemite as well.
Then every time I give that
to someone who's known an
Australian and they eat
and they're like, oh,
this tastes like poison. It.
- Tastes good on toast. It's brilliant.
- Lovely on toast.
- I would just put it on toast.
There's a spread on tasting.
- We can make it work, but put beans.
- You don't, you don't what
else is actually good at,
with is on rice.
Made your mind on rice is
actually not bad because if you
think about it, it's the same
thing as putting it on top.
- I don't know who you offended
more Australian than you or
like the Japanese in you, but you, you,
you somehow like offended both
your ancestors at the same
time.
- Yeah, definitely.
Like I definitely got disowned
the moment I said that on
camera, A rice farm and just died some way
I try to once, because I, I
actually saw it on Japanese,
on Japanese YouTube though,
because that will like, okay.
So my Australian friend brought
back this veggie my thing,
I had it on toast thought
it was disgusting.
But then I thought I'm
Japanese put that on rice.
Anything's good on rice fried it.
And apparently the guy said
it was good. So I was like,
all right, well,
if the guy on the internet
said it was good at Buffalo,
obviously.
- It must be true.
- It must be true. If a
Japanese guy said it must be.
- The truth of the week
says it's good. I'll try it.
- Exactly.
Exactly. So I tried it and I
was like, okay, you know what?
Not as good as on toast, but possible.
- Possibly. Yeah.
I sorry to get back to the
gym to bring it up again.
I was in the gym and I was
watching an anime to go along
with such gym experience.
- That's the only time
you watch animate, man.
You've been talking about
watching animate a lot recently,
twice.
- Twice.
- That is a lot.
- More times than me.
- I want to watch something.
And then I saw the new
season of backy was out.
And I was like, well, this
is good, Jim, of course.
And I watched it in like my God,
if you haven't started
watching Becky, like you need.
- To, I haven't seen this new season yet.
Is it like.
- This is probably the greatest season
of television I've ever seen.
This was so funny. Yeah.
- Cause cause Paul three Bucky,
which is the new season is my
favorite bulky bottom line.
- Honestly. I've I was
like trying to work out,
but I just couldn't stop laughing.
Like just some of the plot
points honestly puts Jojo to
shame at times stupid. This.
- Show is when it really starts to.
- Get fun back is I don't
even know how to explain it.
It's just men with muscles
fighting. And it's just so funny.
- Basically, a kid who's like,
I want to be the strongest
creature on the planet.
And then he does everything
he can to be the strongest.
- There's no way we can describe
in words what back here is
kinda like it's kinda like Joe, Joe,
you kind of just have to explain.
- That's the reason why it
doesn't do is as well as jokes.
I think, I don't know.
It doesn't have like an
aesthetic that is quite as
appealing. The stranger judge has so much,
George has so much style and
stuff to go around with it.
But, but I think Becky
is always more stupid.
- Yeah. Lucky.
Kiska is one of those like
illustrators where I'm like,
are you really good at drawing?
Or are you really sharp?
So I like, like, I don't know.
There were some things where I'm like,
that's an amazing show. And
then other scenes I'm like,
I don't think this man has
ever seen a human being in his
life.
That is not how anatomy works. It's.
- You take a character and you're like,
let's make this a muscly
character. And you're like, well,
what proportions do you
think is reasonable,
reasonable for a muscly character.
And then the author just went, all right,
multiply that by 10. And then
that's the, that's like the.
- Every character, every single character,
even the weak characters, I
like built like brick house.
Right. It's insane.
And like, I could tell you
some plot points and I will,
and they won't even spoil it for you.
So you won't make any sense. Right.
So at one point during the
show, the main protagonist,
Becky start shadowboxing right.
- Is it the mantis?
- So yeah, that as well.
But so you start, this is,
it's like a 10 year old
kid and he's like, look,
I'm going to show you that I'm
going to fight an opponent.
And so he starts fighting
the air and then he starts
fighting Mike Tyson. Oh.
- This one, this.
- One is Tyson appears out of
thin air and Mike Tyson isn't
there. But Mike Tyson is
lending blows and he physically,
physically gets hurt.
And then he's fighting him
back and then the kids can see
the spirit of Mike Tyson.
And then this just happens.
And then he's like, and then
the main character is like,
oh yeah, Mike Tyson's week.
And then he just summons a
praying mantis that beats the out
of him. But then he starts
fighting the praying mantis,
this imaginary.
- In a, in a room, right?
- Like some military guys
like, Hey, come fight.
And then he's like, no.
And then he just kidnapped
George Bush and it's like,
what's going on? What is.
- What is going on?
Then he.
- Kidnaps in this plot.
He kidnaps George Bush.
So he can go to prison. Yeah.
But.
- Like, so then he can
beat up all the prisoners.
- Why would George Bush help
you go to prison? If, if,
if you kidnap him,
they would just watch it
doesn't make any sense.
- I love how is just like it
is. So with the times, like,
you know exactly when Paul three was also.
- Watching Becky, right?
It's like,
if you only learned about
America through trash tastes,
it's, This they say about it.
There's this one,
I had to pause it cause
I just laughed my off.
And this is one point where
this American prison guard is
about to die. And the two
Japanese guys, one of them saves,
the Japanese guy saves the
American and the other Japanese
goes, why would you save an American?
He's never going to care
about you. He's American.
I just post it. And he was
like, what, what does that mean?
What is the, like, what does this trust?
- The Americans like compassion.
What is the, what is that?
- Compassion and my country.
Why would you save it America?
They wouldn't care about.
- Holy.
My FA my favorite Bucky's
on the, I'll never figure.
And I can't wait for them to adopt this.
I think it's part four.
And it's when Barack Obama comes out.
Cause he gets in the manga.
He's like newly elected.
Right? So it's like, you know,
the era of when this was
written and like how my usual,
like the main,
like the dad guy who was
like the most powerful guy,
he's like,
he goes to talk to the bomber
because of course he can.
- Sit down to any page you want.
Like the main antagonist could
just sit down with anyone
just because he's so built different bill.
- But like, but like
Obama at first is like,
I've heard of that, man.
I don't trust him.
I don't trust them at all. But like,
I need to see you see the real deal.
I need to see if he's the real deal.
So then he comes into the
room and he's like, show me,
you're the real deal. And, and
use your, and use your Argos.
All right, bet.
And he grabs like a handful of
sand and he crushes it in his
hand and turns it into a time and.
- I didn't even know
what he's going to do.
- And then Obama's like
you all the real one.
- So there's like, this show is muffly.
If you haven't watched Mackie,
you are honestly doing
yourself. This is so fun.
Let's get past the start.
It can be a little jenky,
but like the animate is
really good. It's really fun.
- 'Cause like, I'm surprised.
I mean, culture just hasn't
picked up on bikinis, right?
Because so much of this is meme of.
- It's so funny. So apparently right,
because these there's these
three characters, Bacchae the,
the, usually a Hanmer and Oliver biscuit.
The other guy was just three guys.
They're so dangerous and so
powerful because their muscles
right that half of the
GPS in the world is,
is on in the air solely to track
this only the track them in
this world.
And so whenever they run
above two kilometers an hour,
the GPS has all the GPS in
the world has to stop working
just to track these.
So there's a whole section
where they explained that when
people are driving or using their phones,
the GPS just doesn't work correctly.
Because some of these characters
decided to go for a light
jog.
You can't make this out of this.
- I'm telling you like, that's the thing.
If people, if you thought
Jojo was ridiculous.
Yeah. Judges witches.
It could be as ridiculous as Baki at time.
- And you combine that with
then also another part in another
season where you drove a Honda again,
the main antagonist meats,
Mohammed Ali, and he, and he's,
he's like, you could,
you can't beat me because you
took off to do important human
rights things. I respect
you because you did.
And it's like.
- What's going on?
- Isn't one of the antagonists,
like Mohammed Ali's son.
- But like respect to Mohammed Ali.
But even though he's weaker
than him, because he went to,
he took time about his career
to, to argue for civil rights.
Great. We love the guy, but
then junior is just like cocky.
And then he gets like.
- But then he like kidnaps, like the main,
like loving just the pocket
and then gets beaten up by like
five dudes for five days straight,
just like over and over and over.
There was also the scene I
love where it's like, honey,
I'm a coder. Who's like
my favorite character.
He's like, he he's like bored.
So he's just like, oh
man, everyone's a week.
Everyone's way. No one can
stand up to me except one man,
call my manager, you know what?
I'm going to go pay him a visit.
So he goes and pays him a visit.
It's just like walking down
the street. And he's like,
so we gonna stop fighting.
And he's like, right here,
I'm like, yeah, that's
in the middle of a crowd.
But then a kid comes up and
is like, oh my God, you draw.
I'm a massive fan of you. And
like handsome, like a squishy,
right? It's like, can
you sign this squishy?
And you know, normally you
think he pulls out a pen?
Does the sign? No, this is a humble user.
He's built different.
What he does is he stab,
he gets his finger.
He stabs the Shishi and then
slices it into four quarters
with his finger.
So it's like all broken
apart. And the kid's like,
oh my God, thank you so much, honey.
Avocado is like, man,
I'd be happier with that than a signature.
And I was like, what is this?
And then they start beating
the out of each other.
- It is insane. Like,
I I'm sure if you don't
know anything about Becky,
that probably sat me no sense.
And it doesn't make any sense.
- Don't.
- Don't in context.
I still don't quite
understand what the story is.
And I've watched three seasons.
I don't get the point of.
- You watched the Netflix and
that's six seasons on even the
beginning of the story. Cause
Netflix seasons are like.
- Starts a season.
It's like a.
- Sequel to an anime or like
the Mongo that came out like
decades ago. And then it's
been going along with it.
- Yeah, yeah.
Yeah. GI has gotten a lot better as well.
On the season. The CGI has kind
of jank in the first season.
I think still watch it.
- I mean, I, I would
say like the animation,
especially compared to
Joe, Joe isn't as good,
but like you don't watch
it for the animation.
You watch it for like the bat crazy stuff.
- It's just like, it's just
insane how they decide fights.
And it is like,
imagine if a world was decided
purely by muscles, like.
- It's like muscles can
solve every world issue
in the world.
- Oh God guns in this world
are meaningless compared to
muscles like guns don't do
any guns or suggest guns for
normal human beings.
And they don't operate in the
same world for the characters
too.
- It's like every single
character is an Avengers level of
threats. That's just what,
that's just what it is.
Right? Yeah.
- And it's every single time
you think you've met the
strongest character? No, they, he,
they introduce some new character
that is even stronger as
the main.
- One in the pile to Regan. Is it the.
- Prehistoric guy? Is it the first human?
- No, sir.
I believe they've done what
they did with the first season
up. They sent me one
season split into two.
I think that's what we've done here.
So the first arc is
just through the prison.
And then the next doc is the,
prehistorical the pickle.
This,
this arc opens up with a press
conference from like a safari
where like all these people
died to this giant mammoth.
- Elephant, which killed
hundreds of people and, and,
and animals.
And in this press conference,
he's like one man killed this,
this 500 meter tall.
Like, and then like the press
conference was like, no, no,
no it didn't. And then
it's like, what is this?
What is so dumb?
That's what I love about Bucky
is that every character has
such as this bat crazy backstory,
the way they get introduced
with this like crazy backstory.
And you have like Speedwagon,
like basically a narrator just
going over their entire bags
with him, doing all of these
like batshit crazy things.
And you think he can't
get crazier until it does.
Every time.
- I've almost caught off to
the manga. And I'm like, how,
how did they top the first
human ever who ever lived?
Who beat a Tyrannosaurus?
- I,
even though I know sort of what
the next doctor about that.
Yeah.
This is an arc about them
fighting prehistoric creatures,
right? Yeah.
There's a lot of what the.
- And they're like,
let's see if they stand up to the humans.
- Today, like Jurassic park instead,
if they turned into test the humans,
instead of like seeing what
the dinosaurs could do,
it's like,
let's see what the humans
can do against the dinosaurs
because humans, humans are
too boring in this world.
Cause it's just like every,
no normal martial arts master
is good enough anymore now.
But it's just so funny because
like the main protagonist,
which is the main character,
his dad is just like bat
insane. And also just hilarious.
It's just so insane. Some
of the he's actually insane.
The fact there's a whole
whole scene dedicated to him
watching his son having sex.
- And that was, that was
what sold me on the first.
Honestly.
- If I can't sell you on Becky is that
there is a scene where
he is about to lose his virginity.
And his dad comes in giving him
advice in like the creepiest
way.
And then he was like, Louis,
please watch this show.
It is insane. The fact that
people haven't watched,
this is just mindblowing. He.
- Literally squats down next
to the bed and says, eat.
- Her, Every day.
- Every day. And see your instincts.
Let your instincts take
over. Become an animal.
When you want.
- Bucky tons.
- Super sand levels.
- He loses a genius.
They have, they have like a,
because like they actually have
sex and they turned the sex
scene into what Jo Jo fights like, oh,
sex sex is like a bat.
- I'm a, be honest though.
It is in real life.
You like trying to think
of like 10 things of this.
Make sure you do it right. Accurate, sexy.
The enemy changed my mind.
No on top of that, right?
Not only is the,
is this the hyper sexy anatomy
immediately after that?
You don't need this. No.
Goku super say, and I'm
going to save the world.
This man powered up more than
GOCO ever wishes. He could,
by losing his virginity.
These people can sense that
this man lost his virginity.
They did.
He was fighting.
- Because one of the prison
guys like trusted, come.
- On. No, no, no, not one,
two before this main character
was so weak that he couldn't
face one of these dudes
one-on-one after sex.
Two of them come in and they
cannot face it like this man's
aura.
This man's Nan has increased
so much from busting a nut.
Like they can't even think
of some that develop.
- Like hockey power.
- And then it's like gone,
turned into his dad after nothing.
It's insane. But it's this
whole episode was like,
you had to pause it and just
be like, what the is going on?
Please watch back. It is insane.
I cannot add this new season was so fun.
I was going to only watch like
two episodes have binged it
all in one day. So fun.
It's insane to watch it.
If you go into the mindset of
this is going to be a kind of
stupid Jojo esque show. I
guarantee you will love it.
If you can watch it with
the boys, the is hilarious.
- We need a Bucky out of
context and a compilation
of barking. So many out of context,
Jo Jo memes and compilations,
but there's nothing for Bucky now.
- I don't, I don't it's it
deserves like it's just every,
I can think of so many clubs,
so many clips of this show
that could deserve to be being,
oh my God.
- Oh my Lord.
- Fight for my life about.
- Yeah. Going back to the gym though.
It's just like how you watch
this when you're doing the gym.
Because like the last thing
I tried watching anime while
going to the gym. Cause I'm
just like, yeah, dubbed.
But like, do you know what?
Get too absorbed into
whatever you're watching.
Cause I can't like, I can't
concentrate on like working out.
If I'm like absorbed into a show.
- Right here. I want to get absorbed
in anything but running.
I want to take my mind
off. Cause the moment I, I,
I want to be staring at my
screen and not at that calorie
counter or the distance treadmill.
- Bike is like, perfect.
- I feel like is amazing
because you can just,
if you have something
that's like an hour 30,
just go and watch. Like if you're,
if you want to watch something,
like I will do my best to just be like,
I'm going to watch this just on the bike.
Cause I, you know, I, to me,
the viewing experience is
nearly identical. Yeah.
It's not as good. And
you're not as comfortable.
I'm not going to say it's the
same thing. But you know, if,
if it's something that you
don't care about too much,
you know, it's not that one
film you've been waiting for.
- Yeah.
Cause like every time I've
watched something while trying to
work out. Cause I remember I, when,
when I still went to the gym.
- I was always watching
YouTube or watching.
- YouTube videos and stuff. I think,
I feel like YouTube is fine,
but like with anime I tried
watching like the new season of
my hair, academia,
I used to do Bosch and I
realized I would watch an episode
and then I would not retain
anything that happened in that
episode. I watch watch the
next episode and I would like,
I'd be so confused as
to what was going on.
- Oh, okay.
Oh wow. Okay.
See, I can normally follow along.
And I mean, because I mean, you know,
when you're doing your
you're working out, right?
Yeah. You're working out
for, you're doing the,
the sets for like what
a minute, minute, half,
two minutes someone's gonna call me, like,
you're doing it all wrong. What the?
But like, you know, you get,
you get on and off time.
So I normally just, I have it
down below, like on the floor.
So I do my through my reps and
I just kind of watch like one
minute and America next rep
and then set it, tell me.
- Oh, I, I can't do that.
Like if I'm doing reps,
like I need to be like fully
concentrated. I need to, like.
- You said, it is really
hard to, to focus.
When the, tell me about this GPS,
he's like laughing too much to do this.
- Bucky would be impossible to watch at.
- The gym like that. All them,
the most muscular men on earth
talking about like the insane
amount of strength and muscles. They have
doing a squat while someone
is talking about how they gain
their muscles. And backy is
like the most like pumped thing.
Like you, can't not go for
the extra wrap, you know,
it's insane. I don't know.
But I, yeah, it is, it
is kind of difficult.
You kind of have to pick and choose.
Now in my head, I have
like media for the gym.
I'm like, this is gym media.
This is stuff that I can watch in the gym.
Cause I don't care too much about it,
but I want to watch it.
And if I, if I care a lot,
I'll stop watching it after
one episode and save it. Yeah.
I like it. Yeah.
And I'll save it for
when I want to watch it.
- If not the secret to getting
Connor, to watch anime,
going to the gym.
- Basically getting me
to do something right.
Maybe not watch, but
obviously right now I've,
I've not been watching anything at all.
I've been just watching
league of legends, but.
- It's kind of.
- Hard. I'm very tired today.
I had four hours of sleep
because I've been watching league
of legends. Pretty good.
I would talk about it.
- I know Joey's not interested
in the toilet quickly,
but basically it's been one
of the most hypers years in
group stages, every fight every year.
- Well the harvest,
the legends is probably the
only sport I try to keep up with
or at least for the worlds,
it is really entertaining.
And I'm sure.
- I'm sure if I understood the rules,
I think I'd really get into it as well.
Cause I like watching e-sports stuff,
but what I actually enjoy about
worlds specifically, well,
does that you get,
I get the same feeling from
worlds as I get watching,
like say the world cup
or something, right.
Where like, even,
even in the smallest stages
you have like really small
regions and you have like
regions that are like across the
world.
And even though you have like
certain countries and certain
regions that are stronger
than others. Yeah.
Like it's still feels like a
global event where you see fans
from all over the world.
Especially when we had a crowds,
just like cheering for even
like teams that are not so
well-known that are like
up and coming regions.
And I really like, I love that
in sporting events when it's,
when it's not just like
one kind of country,
but it's like a global kind of.
- Well, but that's what I mean.
Right. It's like,
I feel like league for me would
be like any other sport that
I just don't know the rules of. Like,
I feel like once you teach
me the rules of like,
what's going on, like how, how, you know,
what's a good play.
- What's not a problem is you need
to let them to play league.
- Right. But I don't want to
do that a hundred percent.
You don't want it.
It's like, you know, it's like, again,
like learning any sport, right.
It's like once you know
the rules, I think it,
you can have a really fun
time of just watching it,
watching it and playing
it. It's totally different.
Yeah.
- That's the reason I got
into league as these players,
as opposed to like, maybe like,
I remember trying to get into
the Overwatch e-sports scene.
me. And oh my God.
Like the game of sides,
which I don't think is as good
of a spectator sport as say
league or something. Yeah.
Like I remember I went
to an event with our,
with our mates and I found out
that they had teams from like
different cities from
across the world. Right.
I was really upset.
And they were like, oh my God,
they have a team from London.
I can't remember what the
exact name, what Spitfire,
London Spitfire team
from London, Spitfire.
I was like, great.
We've got some representation
from the UK and London.
And I remember the team walks
out and everyone is Korean.
And I'm just like, why
would you lie to me?
Like this.
- To me? Like they confused.
I understand it. But it's
like a franchise model.
Right. It's kind of like, you know,
like football teams where you
sell the slot to whoever does
it. But.
- They had, there was no London who was.
- Not a single Londoner.
- To my nose.
The way the Overwatch had
done it is that they had these
team names decided you could
buy in and you getting,
I don't know if you
could choose, but yeah.
It kind of ruined it because
you know, as much as you know,
you know, league of legends has so many,
you're allowed to bring
in foreign imports. Yeah.
- So there's like a maximum
cap to how many people you can
import from other countries. Right.
- If you're rooting for Europe. Yeah.
I'd like to see Europe.
- It's like a Japanese rugby
team at one point with a less
Japanese place than.
- Yeah. Yeah, exactly.
And this year in league, like the Jew,
there was a Japanese team that
qualified for the main event.
And that's the first time I
ever have in history because no
one in Japan who gives a
about league of legends.
So it's just like really small
team quantified for the main
event. And I'm just like, it.
This is the plot line
right here. What the?
Why am I watching animated.
- Strong Neesha? But I just struggles.
Cause there's not a big
PC culture. Hell no, no.
Unfortunately I don't really
see a PC culture taking off any
time soon.
- It's crawling, but it's,
I don't think it's like
dedicated to games likely.
- Yeah. I think it's just mobile
gaming is just too massive.
It is. Yeah.
For like people, because as
we said, people don't have.
- But like stuff like apex is blowing up.
So I think that's been
a real big push for PCC
Yeah. Apex is doing very well in vitro,
but it's only just especially,
at least in Japan very much.
- Yeah. Think.
Cause I think before that,
like the biggest PC game
we had here was like pub G.
Oh yeah. Yeah.
But, and like that was like
the biggest in the dirt.
And I think that was like the
biggest that I'd ever gotten
in Japan in terms of like a PC game.
- PC, like bangs are
popping up a bit in Japan.
They are a.
- PC cafe gaming cafes.
- Chill because we have it in London,
but that was one and it
was so God expensive.
It was like $15 an hour.
Yeah. And it was it's like,
it's it's I understand that you,
you know, you're a business,
you got to make money and
London real estate isn't cheap.
But also it has to come on.
There's gotta be a reasonable
amount. I've got a PC at home,
come on like five bucks
an hour. I'll buy food.
I'll promise. I'll buy food.
You know?
I, I don't.
Yeah.
- It's like a bit of a rip bit too.
- Much because yeah.
If I want to have a full gaming
session with the boys in the
cafe, I spent like a hundred bucks, bro.
I can,
but if I want to play the
entire steam library for that.
- Yeah. What if I want to play
like a game of like SIF two,
which is like 12 hours was rip,
then it's like $300 for GSE.
- It's like, what the?
I think in countries like Korea,
it's a lot more affordable
because they rely more on like
you buying food and drinks and stuff,
which I would prefer I'll
buy food and drink. If.
- Yeah. Cause I feel like in
the UK it's like, it's, it's,
it's a strange concept. You
know where it is in Korea.
It's just a normal way to socialize.
- Yeah. Well, yeah.
I noticed that in Korea,
it was not Korea in the UK.
It was either Chinese students who,
in that old day where it was
kind of like British people,
who'd be like, Ooh, play PC for an hour.
- Ooh.
- It wasn't meant to, unless
you're a rich foreign student,
you're supposed to be there all day.
It's a shame because I
would love to game in a PC.
That's.
- Why, that's why we want to go to Korea.
- We've been saying this before,
but we've always just wanted
to spend like 12 hours a day
gaming. And that's my idea of a vacation.
- It sounds like an amazing.
- Vacation to me. Shut off my phone.
Just game. Yeah.
Look at me game.
- Just get some toxic
gaming in there because I,
I realized how like small,
like how unpopular PC gaming
was in Japan when Nazi joins
the Japanese league of legends
servers. And I was just like,
great. Join the Japanese
league of legends service.
Perfect way to practice my
Japanese and game at the same
time. A little bit.
I realize until like about
like 50 games in no one on the
Japanese league of legends
service speaks Japanese.
No it's all Chinese.
Everyone speaks Chinese or
English because no one Japanese
is playing the Japanese service.
It's just like Chinese Giannis.
People were smurfing
on the Chinese people.
- Just go to like have fun.
- And what I realized is that
it's the most toxic server in
the world that I've been to
because no one Japaneses play.
So it's all smells from
other countries. Just like,
let's just like being toxic on the server.
So yeah. I can see why
Japanese, like it's,
especially with league,
at least why it wasn't
so popular in Japan.
Apex is a different deal,
but basically the secret to
getting a game popular in Japan,
I guess it's just your appeal to beat you.
Just put some gotcha.
Gotcha. Put some gotcha in
league and you're all good.
You got the Japanese market. Oh yeah.
- It's a conceptual game as well.
It's very easy to hop in
and just play a few games.
If you ever guys one.
- Yeah,
one day I saw you playing
Minecraft the other day now I'm so
disappoint. You started without me.
I was invited.
- To suffer boys.
- I saw you dying in the
lava like five times. Listen,
we don't talk about it.
We'll play Minecraft. Yeah.
I've got to get myself situated first.
Cause I've recently just
moved as well. It was a,
what are your places?
Goodie was an interesting
moving experience mostly because
of all the that Sydney has
built up over the years.
Okay. So we hired the same
moving company, right?
So, so there's this main guy
and he knows that where YouTube
was. Cause he moved,
he moved all the trash,
all the trash day stuff. Right.
I don't think he was prepared.
Like he knew that we
were anime fans. Right.
But I don't think he was prepared
for some of the stuff that
Sydney had.
Like just within her closet.
I remember. So yeah.
Before, before, so before,
before they do the move,
they also have to like scout
the place just to see what they
have to move and how many
trucks have to rent out.
And Sydney, Sydney was
just like, you know what?
I know the stuff, I
know my room's a bit of,
a bit of a nuclear like
wasteland right now. You know,
I'm going to clean it up a bit. Right.
So what she does is she takes
off all like the lewd posters
off a wall, right.
She's like, I'm going to,
I'm cleaning up my room.
You know, he's not going
to notice cleaning up,
cleaning up my room. So she
takes off all the loo posters.
Thank you. She's got a job done.
I've got nothing to worry about.
What she forgets right. Is
there's no posters on the wall,
but there's just a massive
pile of sex toys that she just
somehow forgot about.
You really know how numb she
is to that kind of where it's
like, oh yeah, there's
nothing wrong with that.
Right.
It's the of the round sign art, right?
Then it's the 10 kilogram boobs
that are just lying on the
floor. So she forgets to hide
that, but she takes softer,
slightly lewd posters off the wall.
Distasteful gone.
Now the guy opens the door
and is greeted by just the 10
kilogram boobs that are just
sitting on her desk that she
somehow just forgets about.
He probably wanted to like
get out of there. Yeah.
And so, yeah.
So I'll figure after we
get everything packed up,
obviously he like, they
hired different people.
So he he's seen all this before,
but obviously his employees
haven't seen this. Right.
And so they have to, they
have to pack everything up.
Right. And so how it was,
they packed everything up.
There were about like
four men just loading,
loading stuff into the
two trucks that we had.
Sydney stayed behind.
Sydney, stayed behind to clean
up a place after we had all,
we were all driving to our new
place to unpack everything.
And I sat with them in one of
the vans and I sat with them
with two of them. And two of
them weren't the main guy.
So it was just one of their
employees. And it was just like,
it was like a good 15,
20 minutes of silence.
Right.
And we were just driving along
and the guy next to me just
goes so interesting stuff. He got there.
I was like, oh my God.
So it's like, I'm starting to explain the.
Right. So it's like, you
know, this is just, you know,
where you tubers and the room
that, that room, that room,
you know, that room.
That's not my room.
- That's like trying to explain
what b-boy is unfortunate.
Right. It's like, ah, yeah.
So there's a little up sheet
here, but don't worry about it.
It's totally fine.
- Yeah.
- I showed them all the cost
plays I had. They were like,
what, why do you have so many costumes?
Why is there so many dresses?
You're like, I don't know.
That's my job.
- To say.
- Well,
what's worse to say if it's
your job or if it's your hobby.
- The guy walked in my room
was like, so you're single.
Huh?
- I'm glad Sydney was there.
Cause if it was just me sorting
this out, like I kind of,
how do I explain that?
How the do I explain that?
So yeah. I live, I live with a fiance.
I know she collects sex toys
and reviews them on a YouTube
channel. And they'll
just like, yeah, sure.
Review. I was like, yeah, sure, bet.
Bet.
It's not even the worst
part because after,
after I have this like a half
an hour explanation explains
to them what we did and
just, you know, just,
just explain the situation
so they understand.
So we get to the house and
so they start loading stuff,
you know,
first goes the beds and then
all of like the other boxes and
then the big stuff.
And then I had scheduled the
gas guy to come on the same day
because you know, we've got to
turn on the gas or maximize,
you know, midmaxing, midmaxing moving.
Yep.
So I got a phone call from
the gas guy, as every,
as everyone's coming in, packing,
unloading all the stuff into
the house, I'm like, oh, I'm,
I'm about to come over. Is that cool?
And I'm like, great, perfect.
I'm here right now. Just come right in.
So he comes in checks,
the gas thing turns it on.
Does the check everything's
perfect. And as he's,
as he's about to walk down the
stairs, guess what pops up?
It's the 10 kilogram boobs
right in front of him.
The guy just like presents where
I'm on a silver platter and
the guy.
- Inside of like a box or anything like.
- That. He was, he was inside
a box, the box, the packaging,
which is just an anime girl
with her breast cell. Right.
Because this thing, this thing
doesn't need to go in a box.
It is its own box. It's just boobs.
That is 10 kilograms. The
box is big enough by itself.
So he just, he stops.
They both stop. The gas guy looks at him.
It looks at him, looks down at the box.
It looks at me and he
goes, oh, very important.
- So he's like, yes.
- It's got a sense of humor.
- The guy. So what is the guy
was like, oh, a one of them.
- Yeah. I'm just, I just
phoned Sydney up afterwards.
I'm just like, why did, why
did you give me this job?
I should be the one cleaning up.
You should be the one handling with.
- Really necessary to keep.
- I also didn't need to go in
the box that had all the loose
in front of it.
Like you couldn't have just put
it into like the moving box.
- I, we let the movers pack.
What I did with.
- All my loose is that I packed it
in a box separately before
the moving people came.
So they had no idea of all
the coasts should I have in my
house.
- I try to pack as much stuff as I could,
but there's too much stuff
because when they pack stuff,
I just lost track of
everything. I was like,
I don't know which box everything's in.
- I tried to like help them
and like try to keep track of
everything. And then like
about two hours in you realize,
I don't know where anything is anymore.
- And, and so like, even like
a month after I was like,
which box is that one specific
thing I need in, I terrible.
The boxes can't find
it. And I'm like, well.
- I'm. Yeah.
Like I still haven't found
my wireless headphones,
which is somewhere in one of the boxes.
I like you forget about the
little items that you kind of
need in day-to-day life until
you're staring at about 20
boxes in front of you. And
you realize that, oh, this,
this one thing is in one
of these boxes. Like.
- I guess how does that
happen? Every time I've sweat.
Like, I, it doesn't matter who I ask,
how far they're moving,
how much stuff they have,
every move items.
Just like go into some Donnie
Darko happens where it's just
like disappears into a
void on the way it's like,
cause like you, you look at it.
Cause I had that as well
where I was like, okay,
I'm missing like two or three items.
At least I went back to the old house.
Obviously not there ring
up the moving company.
They say they don't have
it. I'm like, well the,
where the did it go?
You're not going to tell me
it's in one of these boxes
because you opened it all
up and still not there.
What do I do with it?
- Oh, I miss moving.
As a student, you just
had like two suitcases.
You just Chuck, everything
away, you don't need.
- The thing is when you're moving,
when you have like an apartment stuff,
you just forget how much is
hidden. So, so you panic.
- Such a nightmare. Yeah.
You.
- Pack the big. And you're
like, oh, I'm like 80% done.
Then somehow you add another
three hours of packing on top
of that because there's such so much.
That's just accumulated random.
- I was surprised how
much was in my kitchen.
My kitchen is like two boxes, three boxes.
It was like 15 boxes. Just kitchen.
I'm like, how is this?
Why do I own so many spoons
and plates? What is this?
I didn't know. I owned that much.
I have like four different
types of plates. I don't,
I already use one.
- Because he like go deep
into like Cubs that you open.
Like once every like couple
months. And he's like, oh, okay.
I didn't realize I had 17
bottles of dishwashing liquid.
Just like sitting back there.
- Yeah. Yeah.
Dude, man,
getting rid of all the
cardboard after moving was so.
- Dumb. Don't talk to me about that.
- 18,000.
I probably had a Japanese
forest worth of cardboard in my
apartment. At one point.
- It was, we ordered,
they took all the cardboard
with them cause they unpacked it
all for us.
- Don pocket.
Doesn't that service cost like 10 grand,
but we were sponsored.
- Nice. Nice.
For some nice. For some, I just.
- I just can't in good faith.
Pay 10 grand for them to move my stuff.
- If I didn't get sponsored
by it, I wouldn't have paid.
- For it. Just like the one
that they charged me, like two,
I think to rent, which I was like, okay.
Yeah, that makes sense.
I guess it's a full day
of work. It's a full tank.
It's a truck.
You thrown away stuff to
get. That makes sense.
- It makes it somewhere.
- So they got to make a profit
man, but cycling out here.
Cause I saw your moving company.
Someone was moving into my
building and it was like,
the whole place had been
like taken over by them.
There was like 15 of them on.
- The elevator. And like
the outside is like.
- No wonder they cost like 10 grand.
They they've got the whole
dark Japanese workforce here
doing this stuff.
- They really they're really
all like, I don't know why.
I guess they're really
prideful of they company or
something.
But like they love plastering
their logo all over the,
I mean, it seemed like a.
- Yeah, it seems like
a military operation.
So it's like,
let's see from the anime where
they call the SDF like, oh,
get the STF down here, man.
This the, this is a real job.
Now.
- I understand, man.
If you've got a family,
you've got kids and and
you're doing pretty well for
yourself. I get it.
I trying to move with my
kids. Like I would like,
I would not want to be in my
situation that I was in plus
kids. I understand that.
It's like, yeah, just bring in the SAS,
bring in the Marines, bring
in John senior that do it.
Like I do not want.
- Especially if you were,
you know, like, you know,
in your 60 seventies,
it's like, you just do it.
- 'Cause I guess as you
get older, you know,
you won't be moving
nearly as often. You know,
I still don't know if I'm
going to move into a years,
four years, but it, once I'm like 40,
I'm probably going to be staying
there for a good amount of
time.
Wow.
- That is a late time to settle.
- Down anytime soon you kidding me,
but I get you unless I become
a billionaire hedge fund, man,
then I'll just buy 15 properties, live 11,
whichever suite I want to.
- Private jet.
- What's my one day these
stocks are going to turn green.
And I tell you, man, I tell you that.
- I can't settle down.
If you're settled in five
different countries, same time,
great.
- Big brain.
- I I'm still going through
that phase where I'm like,
I'm in my thirties now.
I should probably think about
where I want to settle down.
But just like, that's just like.
- I feel like settling down
is when your, you know,
when you're stopped,
when you're working in a place
that you feel like it's going
to be your end.
I don't think I'm going
live in Japan forever.
I can't speak the language.
And even if I did, I'm like what?
I want to raise a kid here. Probably not.
So I don't know.
- Yeah. There's like a lot of,
there's a lot of different
factors that go into like my
longterm sediment, like where
would want to settle down?
Like I do like Asian culture and you know,
I do like live in Japan,
but a big thing about Asia is
that I don't want my kids to
go to school here because my God,
they put so much pressure on
exams and schooling here that
I'm just like this, this is too much.
This is too much.
- I saw a post on
Facebook. Like, you know,
Japan per capita has like the
least exams of any country.
And it was like before
high school, I was like,
oh that's great. Yeah.
So just let them be happy until
age 12 and then just them.
- They're really happy. And it's like,
give them heaven for about 12
years and then give them hell
for the next three.
- That makes so much sense
because Japanese kids like so cute.
You like whenever you see
school kids, they're so nice.
Say hello. You know, they, they just,
they're just so inquisitive
and everything. And then like,
you start some of these,
like it's before they learn like a flip.
But I swear like every Japanese
teenager goes through the
same moody teenager phase.
Like it's, it's like, there,
there is no exception.
- I'm telling my kids get cocky when they,
when racism is the same as it is. Right.
It's like it's cause like,
cause I can tell like,
cause you know, sometimes
with Japanese kids, right,
just from looking at them,
you don't know how old these,
some of these kids are.
Like, there are some like,
ten-year-olds that look 30 and
there are some 30 year olds
that look tan.
But like you can always tell though,
when it's like a middle school,
Japanese kid and a high
school, Japanese kid.
No, from the looks, but from the attitude,
how happy they are.
- How happy they.
- Are.
And just from the attitude towards how,
I guess they like talk to foreigners,
I guess in a sense like.
- High school students are very
scared of talking. They are.
- But middle school and
like elementary school,
Japanese kids love talking to.
- Children.
- In the street.
- Not going around, going
like hello to every child.
- But yeah, in my old,
my old apartment block,
the only people who would
ever like converse with me,
I like the little kids whenever
I get stuck in the lift and
I'm like, oh, what's the
word you want to go to?
Where'd you come from? I'm just like, oh.
- I'm talking to, and then some,
I don't know what happened.
Something in high school
happens where they just suddenly
become paranoid of foreigners.
- Life. Like just they ruin their life.
Yeah. And then with the
expectation, but you.
- Also know,
but you also know which high
school student dropped out
because they're very happy.
They're like, how are you?
Yes. I'm not in school anymore.
Doing really good for
myself. Thank you very much.
Don't have to go through 17 exams a year.
- I just wouldn't want my kid
going through the system again.
Yeah. Same.
Also if Japanese banks
are like this, God knows,
God knows what the rules are
like with Japanese schools.
Oh my lowest being a parent.
Having to deal with that.
- I think,
I think though it depends
heavily on the score that you go
to. Like obviously,
like I think public schools
definitely have it the worst.
I think that's the same
with any country out there.
But you know, if you go to, like,
if you take your kid to like
a private school or even an
international school, like
I think it gets a little.
- Bit better. Yeah.
- Totally.
Oh, I don't plan on
having kids anytime soon.
- No. I mean either that's the
problem for like future me to
figure.
- Out the trash tastes episode 5,000
5,000 kid. himself.
Am I right?
- Can you relate?
- So I went fishing this weekend. I know,
I know we were talking about
our trash chase fishing
special. I'm sorry guys.
I'm sorry.
Lynn Malin was one who invited me.
I blame, I blame Merlin.
I.
- Trusted you. Melaine.
- Malin. Just invited us, me and Sydney.
If we wanted to have like a kind of kind,
kinda like a double day where
we go fishing together and
I've really enjoyed. It
looked like you were.
- Enjoying it. Like you were
about to shoot your shot.
- Oh yeah. So like, okay, so this is,
so this is the first time
where I went sea fishing.
So it wasn't like it wasn't a
fishing in a river or a lake,
which I've done before on a
boat before. So, so it is,
it is an entirely different
experience, right?
Mostly because I've never been
seasick in my life. Right.
And we were talking about this. So on,
on the journey up there,
everyone's like, oh,
does anyone here get seasick?
Which is if you get seasick
and you're about to go fishing
on the sea pro probably
a bad idea at time. Yeah.
But none of us had ever
been seasick before.
So we're like great
fishing on and see easy.
What we didn't realize is what
I didn't realize is that when
you're actively doing,
doing things and having to
concentrate things on top of
being on the sea and being
on the edge of a boat,
it like amps up your sea sickness to 10.
So this is the first time I'd
ever felt queasy on a boat.
Right.
But I mean the, the entire thing was like,
aside from having to deal
with the sea sickness, it was,
it was pretty fun. So what happened is we,
we went down to Yokohama and
we went to the port there.
And so we are the, we have,
they have this package where
you basically go out to sea for
about four hours.
I think it was like, yeah, about,
about four seven at a
time, these amount of time.
And basically whatever you catch,
you can keep and you can do
whatever you want with the fish.
So back when I went
fishing in Wisconsin, we,
whatever we caught, we could
only keep a certain amount,
but here you can like keep
whatever you want and you can
cook them afterwards as well.
And so, yeah.
So we went out to see, and
I remember at the beginning,
so it was me, Sydney Malin and marquee.
Right. And so obviously
he was our first time.
So the fishermen was trying
to teach us how it was done.
Right.
And within the first hour
Maillian catches too immediately.
Right. And, and she's, she's just,
she's just on fire right now.
She's like, I'm a natural,
I'm a natural. Imagine how smart she was.
So smug didn't catch anything
for the rest of the trip.
and like, and like on the
opposite side of things,
which was Sydney and while Malin
was like catching her first
two with a now city,
he was like struggling to get
like the real town. Right?
Like, like the,
the fishermen was like next to
her for like a full-on hour,
like explaining to her then
explained to her again.
And like, like here, he
was like Eagle lied on her,
just try and try to make sure
that she was doing everything
correctly because she was
not getting any catches.
And then somehow like offer an hour in.
She just starts reeling and
fished. Like it's no business.
She starts catching like four
or five fish at the end of it.
Once the controller finally play the game.
And then there's McKee,
which Paul Guy who's made in
his husband McKee poor guy
courts. I think, I think he
caught like one fish at the end.
And so did I? No, actually
I caught like three or four,
but most of them were two big
different. The one I caught,
I caught one fish that I could
keep and the rest were just
like too small to even be worth
because stabs and because marquee
unfortunately was like way
too seasick to be able to
function for most of the trip,
which is the thing, which
is the thing where Malin,
Malin also was seasick.
And so aside to be fair,
Malin being Malin was didn't
want to admit it. Cause she,
she, she was,
she was like really silent
after about an hour,
she was just sitting
down and I was like, man,
and you're right. And she was like, yep.
Yep. I'm cool.
I'm just, I'm just,
just a little bit tired,
a little bit tired.
She told me afterwards that
she just didn't want to admit
she was sea sick in case like
you, Cindy would be like,
oh no little baby on one of
your medicine for seasickness,
which we totally would have done anyway.
But as soon as soon as Marcie
mentioned that he was feeling
seasick, she turns to me
and Cindy was like, Marquis,
seasick. She sees sick.
I'm taking care of Marquis.
Wow. I'm like, wow, what an.
And I was just like, I'm seasick as well.
You know, obviously I'm
not, I, you know, it's,
it's normal to get season
just like the blinking light.
But it was so funny. Cause McKee
did a Markey's first catch.
Right?
He, he, he reeled in two
little, like super small fish.
They were like baby fish. Right.
They were like this big, you know,
you can't do anything with them.
So it's like at this point
you just catch and release
everything.
And it was the first like baby
fish we caught on the day and
this was about two hours in.
And so he caught them and I was like, oh,
look at the little baby
fish though. You know,
we should probably probably
release them. So we,
he takes the hook out and he starts like,
he puts them back in the ocean
and they start swimming off.
I know, I swear to God,
this thing is like,
this is like a scene
from the Simpsons. Right.
Or you can see them swimming
off and Sydney in her little
and her little, you know,
Sydney is just like,
talks about a dog or it
talks about any animals.
She's like go swim,
little baby swim, swim.
And then as soon as she finishes
saying that out of nowhere,
a seagull peers and just
dive bombs to fish out of the
water.
And he'd said,
the four of us were just
standing there looking at this
atrocity in silence.
Like, well,
has been restored.
Oh my God. But it was actually like,
it was actually like a
really fun experience.
I've how much was it to go on the boat?
It was like about a hundred
dollars. So the person,
and you could catch as
much fish as you want. And,
and afterwards, so you,
you go catch the fish and afterwards you,
they have different services so off.
So you can go to an area where
they can cook the fish or you
can go to an onset.
And so there was this
onset that we went to,
which is perfect. Like if
you're fishing for four hours,
it's surprisingly tired.
It's like way more fishing
on the sea is way more active
than doing lake fishing
or a river fishing. Right.
Because you're, you're,
you're batting against the
current and your constantly like,
it's way more,
it's way more active because I
don't know what they call it,
but they, they give you the,
you the like this little cage.
Right.
So you've got the bait,
which is on the hook or the
next to the Bates is this little
cage where you basically
stuffing stuff in like fish,
like dead fishes or, oh,
is that what it's called?
Okay. Okay.
Oh, oh.
That's why it's called a chum bucket.
Oh my God. It makes so much sense.
Now camera's like just
mashed up fish. Yeah.
So they gave us a chum bucket.
I guess I was struggling
to find the worst.
Describe this thing.
It's a chum bucket man.
Discover SpongeBob.
So we had a chum bucket.
And so we had to fill up
this cage full of charm.
And the cage itself would
attract the fish school with the
smell.
And the bait itself would like
attract the fish to bite on
it. Unfortunately like the
chum would like disintegrate.
Well then like, you know, within
a good five, five minutes.
So like every, every,
every five minutes you'd
have to like put it down,
pick it back up, put it
down and pick it back up,
fill it out, fill it up again
and fill up the Chomper,
fill up the chum cage with more
chum from your chum buckets.
And so it was actually like
way more of an accurate yes or
Ganson. Your favorite word is now.
- You're going to be feeling
we're going to be hearing this a lot.
- And so it was a way more active.
It was way, way more active
than the other kind of fishing I
experienced. So I was
actually pretty tired.
I, it was, I worked up a
good sweats and my God,
the onset afterwards, you know,
you know how you know how
after a hard day's work or how
you've done, like, you know,
after a hard day's work on.
- It catches one baby
fish, that was a hot,
sweating up a storm getting again.
- I, I did catch one fish.
I caught the biggest fish of the day.
Sydney caught the most fish,
but I caught the biggest fish.
- Tastiest though. Huh?
Was yours.
- The taste? Of course it was mine.
Of course. What fish did you catch?
The tasty ones you have? Oh,
I can't remember the type of fish I had.
I believe it was a sea fish.
Do you remember the type of
fish that we were catching?
- Oh, that's not the cheap fish, right?
That's like the though, right?
That's the you put in the can,
but that's like the cheap,
like when you go to sushi places,
that's like the cheapest one.
it's the white one, right?
Yeah. It's the cheapest.
When you cut it open, it's like really,
really white with the silver outline.
- It's like the,
it's like the blue with
like a little bit of yellow
in the fish.
- Maybe I'm totally wrong.
Like.
- They do have like different
services where you can catch
different types of fish,
but like the good fish.
- That sounds cool. Let's do that.
The good.
- Oh yeah. Next time.
Next time.
Because you go to this onset
and while you're in the onset
and just chilling out
with the boys or whatever,
they're preparing your fish, right?
So they take your fish and so they take,
take your catch and they
feed it to you afterwards.
- You said that, that just made me,
I had the immediate image of
somebody coming out of that.
- Open your mouth open.
He comes here, which is,
which is great. I mean, what better?
What better splice can you.
- Monkfish in ruins scape.
That is a high level of fish or shark.
- Or something. Yeah.
It wasn't high enough level.
- You can't catch it. The level.
- Of that fish. Yeah.
You can't catch different
types of fisheries,
but the best fish come
out at like 7:00 AM.
So it's like a 7:00 AM when I'm just like,
I'd like to try fishing.
- Fishing.
- That's that's, that's
like after, you know,
five tries or something, that's
when you're like dedicated,
that's one where you have like
your own fishing rods and all
that, you know.
You know, you're, you know, you're legit.
- When you got your own equipment.
- Fishing order is just
one of those devices
that I feel like is such a big investment
because of how knowing it is to
maintain that break.
- Also like when you
get like super serious,
there's like different
roads for different fish.
It's like, oh my God.
It's like.
- I learned that from tales of rice.
- You know, one of the
short, when I'm fine,
if I'm 50 and I haven't decided the hobby,
I think as a white person, that
is the default hobby I have.
Yeah. I think when I get
to 50, we'll see that in.
- Golf. Oh wait the suitcase.
I'm going to be like, yeah.
- We'll see Bob have a
hobby by then. I don't know.
Maybe I want my hobby.
- Now.
- A couple of streaming
when I'm 50, I'll be like,
I'll be like, let's get
my dentures and myself.
I, I can't.
- It's not that old guy
who's like used to stream or escape a lot.
- The guy.
- Tried to cancel.
He's still streams. Right?
I'm pretty sure. I think so.
So there's a future, man.
- I mean, maybe I'm already
like low in energy now.
- Oh man, you say that,
but you stream more than me and Joey.
- I feel like I'm really low on energy,
but then you guys are
always don't sleep much. So.
- I think there's a difference
between law and energy
and con you know, not being.
Yeah.
That's like, I'm not low in energy.
I just can't be.
Yeah. Maybe, maybe.
- Yeah. Yeah.
I mean, I, I can't tell if I'm learning,
like I am alone and just.
- Throw my kidney.
- I have to conserve my
energy for trash tastes.
People think I talk a lot
and then no, it's just like,
I can serve all my,
all my like social energy
for trash tastes every week.
And then not like I've reset every week.
- It's hard work in this, in this show.
But honestly.
- Though, if I stream,
then that's my work done for
the day because I can do it in
the night.
How do I have energy after I've
been working all day to also
stream, which is to me work.
- Sometimes you start streaming
and then you just kind of get
energy. That's just streaming.
It's just that sometimes it happens.
Like sometimes I'm really
dreading. It's called.
- And extra for like,
literally it's like your gig.
You're gaining the energy.
You're siphoning the energy
from social interaction. Right.
For me, it's the opposite.
Like I have a certain amount
of energy and I have to expel
that during the day. Basically.
- I be it out. What do you bring out?
Have no more shooting.
They promise no more.
- It's just like gone, goes to the toilet.
And Sydney's like, are you
expelling your energy honey?
Yesterday,
Tony dropping me during my
energy expiration period.
- How else are the moving stuff going?
You kind of getting settled
in, is it you dreading.
- It's because this is,
it's a bit different now
because I lived in apartment and
this one's a house and it.
This was actually where I was
actually really lucky to get
this house because the
previous owner has gotten a job
abroad. And so he was very
desperate to find a tenant.
So we got it out like a amazing
price. Cause we were like,
when we were looking for other
places, we were, we were,
we didn't even know if we
were going to move because I
remember talking to you guys
because you both were moving,
you wanted bigger places. And I'm like,
I'm actually really happy with my place.
I suppose, a good size.
It was a good size. And I was just like,
I'm only going to move if I
can find like a decent enough
upgrade.
And we saw other places which
for the budget that was set
and nothing was really like,
nothing really standing out.
I was just like, whatever.
Maybe I'll just stay for another year.
And then this was like the
last house that we looked up
because the estate agent
was like, yeah, we have,
we have one more on offer.
That's essentially we
saved the best for last.
And so we looked at this house
and it was like twice the
size of any other place they'd
shown us for the same price.
And we're like, what the though?
Is there is a catch though, which is,
I don't know what the
exact contract was called,
but we only have it for
a maximum of two years.
So that was the catch after the hour.
So after two years we have to get.
- Our switches. If you're like,
get really settled in you really? Like.
- When we were looking for
places for the trash taste office
that we, one of the
places we will consider,
I don't know if we talked
about this on camera,
but one of the places we were
considering was exactly the
same. The first place we found,
it was like this like three
story house that was like,
oh yeah, this is like, it
looks like a perfect space.
But then we found out
that, oh yeah, it was like,
it was owned by an ex-pat
who was overseas now.
But he was like, I'm
coming back in two years.
So you better get the out. But I.
- Think this one's actually
better in the end. I think.
- Definitely, definitely
better in the end.
But like initially when we
were looking at new studios,
that was one that we were
really happy with because it was
like good price, good location.
- So in the end, what,
what made you move there?
Was it just cause the
like the house, the house.
- So the location was
amazing. The house is amazing.
And I was just like, I,
I move on average every two years anyway.
So like I do it as we just discussed.
I'm not one to settle down. So I.
- Mixing it up, you know, I like,
I like getting as annoying
as it is. Like I do like it.
- Two years is a long time.
If you think about it,
to me at least three, two
years is like a long time,
especially for.
- It's something exciting
about upgrading a little bit as
well.
I've been working hard.
This is a little bit of an
upgrade and give myself a pat on
the back three times more
expensive than my old one.
But that's because I didn't
know how I was going to do
financially when I moved here.
- I mean, yeah, when I
first moved here, I had.
- One.
- Bedroom. I don't want.
- Yeah, same here because
when I moved here,
Sydney just didn't have a
career yet. So it was like,
it was a lot of, it was on a
lot of, it was on me to like,
well, she, she sh you know, she,
she obviously paid for it
as well, but a lot of it,
a lot of it was if it
rested on you, if like,
if Sydney falls through
and her YouTube career,
doesn't take off, then all of
this is going to fall on me.
And that's why I was like,
that's what I was thinking about.
But now it's a lot more
comfortable. We can vote,
share the costs.
So we were able to have
like a bigger budget,
but still not stupidly large.
And yeah, we just found a
nice, really nice house.
And then Sidney's.
- Career took off and
we went stupidly lost.
- And my, my mind, I was like,
cause we were living so far away.
We had to say where we live
now. Kind of like, say,
I don't want to go on.
I'm just wondering it was.
- It was, we didn't live in the center.
It was very.
- Far away, very far away.
It's kind of was kind of,
and I also live really
far away from the station.
So I felt like double damage.
- For me. I lived literally
three minutes away from this.
- I actually had like the nicest insights.
And then I lived like, ridiculous.
Like, I didn't.
- Know, like halfway between two stations.
I.
- Remember. Yeah.
Yeah.
And so I had the really annoying
case of just like I'm 15
minute walk to one station,
20 minutes to the author.
Yeah.
Which like, doesn't seem like a big deal.
But when you,
some days when you have to go
back and forth multiple times,
it really felt dreadful. Yeah.
And I just got to the
point where I'm like, okay,
I'm doing well for myself.
I'm just going to spend
the extra money just to get
somewhere that's super close
and that I can focus more on
work. Don't have to worry about traveling.
Like now I don't have to
worry too much about before.
I always had to plan it
precisely when I was leaving the
house because I had to, I had
to look what the train was.
I had to make sure I was getting
the express train because
it was so far away that you
could get an express train that
saves you quite a
significant amount of time.
And so normally commutes
for about an hour for me,
which is quite a long time.
And did you have to really think, okay,
what am I leaving the house? But now,
now I can just kind of be like, all right.
I generally know what
time I need to leave.
- I kinda liked the commute though.
Cause like may currently I'm
also like just like travel
distance for me, like to
the office, for example,
is like pretty much the same as it was.
It's not that much different. Time-wise,
it's just in a different.
- I always complained about
it the most, because for me,
I definitely valued distance
from where I was going along.
- I really liked the commute
though for somebody because it
puts my mind off of work
for even just having.
- But I,
I liked it until a certain
point because commuting here was
fine.
Commuting back is a
nightmare because like,
I would always dread it. Right.
Because commuting, I don't
mind staying on the train,
but when it's like, when
you're going back off,
we finished filming trash
tastes normally like in London,
it's like the rush hour is from,
let's say five o'clock
till seven o'clock right.
Where it's like, the Chub is parks.
You're not getting a seat.
And you're like a sardine for some reason,
the rush hour in Tokyo starts
from like four till like nine
30 or nine.
- Right? Yeah.
No it doesn't, it doesn't name
it goes on until midnight.
- Yeah. So, so like,
so like the commute back
was just like a nightmare.
I would like dread it.
So I would dread the
commute back every time.
So it was just normally
if I was in London,
I would just wait out the
rush hour. But in Japan,
there is no waiting of
the rush hour. You just,
you just got to deal with it.
- Well, it depends.
Right? Because like some, like you said,
you don't mind the commute. That's good.
I mean, very Opie for you.
You can get a much bigger
place. Would you ever,
you have a much better place than me.
So it's, it's kinda like, I dunno.
I just, I hated commuting.
And to me I felt like I could
spend my time better and I did
want to spend my time differently,
like streaming, right?
Like an extra hour of
streaming is a big difference,
like a long way. So yeah.
- Yeah. I think for me as well as,
because like an hour commute
for me now is so much better
than what I first had
when I first moved here.
When I first moved here,
I lived in a place that was a
25 minute walk to the closest
station I up.
And it was like way out of
Tokyo kind of thing. So like,
you know,
commuting into Tokyo would
be like an hour and a half,
two hours.
- Which is the walk don't
get me wrong. It's fine.
Walking is not the problem
it's walking in the summer.
Sometimes, you know,
you can't always be what you'd
like you sometimes you have
to carry a bunch of.
And that's where it really sucks.
- The have so glad that finally
I'm able to wear a sweater.
It's so nice. Now, like
speaking of whether the, like,
where did autumn go? Yeah.
It's just, it just was
like tea for two days.
And then he's like, all right.
So you just turn into winter. It's.
- Always like that.
- I'm so glad though,
because I can finally wear
some drip without dripping
myself.
It's disgusting for like
the middle of September was.
- Yeah. I mean, like,
I just like how Japan decided
that it was going to be hot
until it wasn't one day and
then it just decided it wasn't.
- Well,
it went from 25 to 14 in one
day and it doesn't look like
it's going back, but how does that happen?
Whether.
- Japan has full seasons, everybody.
That's what they tell you. No.
- It has a pain for six months,
then mild discomfort for two
and then the restaurant. Okay.
I guess it's kind of,
it's kind of that right?
- One biggest thing,
going back to the house at one
biggest thing that I've had
to go to get used to living in
the house is a living on the
ground floor. Now I've only
lived, I've only lived in Japan.
I mean,
it's though I've only lived
in apartments in Japan before,
and I was like quite high
up in my old apartment.
So you know what?
I could stand next to the
window and be pretty confident
that no one was going to
Sue me. You know, you know,
especially, you know, when you sleep, you,
sometimes you just sleep
in boxes as, as, as you do.
And sometimes,
sometimes you just out of the
shower and you don't dress
exactly. You didn't get
dressed straight away,
you put on your boxes or whatever,
and you just walk around the apartment.
And I, I kind of realized that
you can't do that in houses.
So our house has like
pretty big windows. Right.
And so I have a shower put on
my boxes and so the bathroom
or my shower room and my
wardrobe is on different floors.
Right. So finish some shower,
go up to go up to my living
room and just, you know,
chilling, you know, before
I put on some clothes,
go up Souk,
go up to my window to like
admire the view as you do
sometimes just admire the
sunshine and ground floor,
admire the pavement on the
first floor on the first floor.
Okay.
So a little elevation, a
little bit of direction,
because sometimes when I
was on, when I was on the,
when I was on the eighth floor,
back in my own apartment,
sometimes you just like, look
down, breathe in the sunshine.
And I thought I'd do the same routine.
So I was just standing in my
window and then someone opens
their,
someone goes up to the balcony
to put out some clothes and
me and them meet high contacts. And I,
I totally not used to this
because back then when you're in
apartments,
I was used to just being by
the window and nobody could see
you because you're too high up to be seen.
And then,
so we make eye contact and then
they immediately just close
the close sliding door again.
And then I realize I'm just
standing next to my window with
my boxes out. And people
can very visibly see me.
And I'm like, was the,
this person they were
like across the road.
So 10 minutes away, it's
like 10 minutes away.
So they had 4k definitions,
literally, literally Cohen 4k,
my God, if it was made
in, she would like be,
she would have seen my nipples
and everything scarred for
life there. I fallen right off the bat.
He's shock like a new place. So, so far.
Yeah. Yeah.
Everybody liked him. Yeah.
Nice.
Also another thing I had to go
back to my house by myself to
pick up some stuff pretty
late at night. And it's, it's,
it's pretty scary to go back. It's,
it's creepy as to go in
the house. And I didn't,
I didn't realize that until I went in,
because when you're in an
apartment, there are like lights,
like outside of your building,
there are lights and our
people live next to you.
You go in this house and it's
just pitch black and you're
just by yourself. And
you're like, you know what?
I wasn't afraid of the dark
until I experienced this.
And I'm going to sound creepy
about an empty apartment.
Pitch-black there was something
really weird about the
apartments.
Like I can handle in an apartment
because the worst thing,
if you, if something happens,
if like a murder is there
or a burglar is there,
you can scream and people
are people around too.
It's confidence in people.
I think, I think you like your
neighbors a little too much.
I don't know. It's probably
just like a placebo,
but tons of motorists in
Japan, but I don't know.
Maybe it's a placebo, but it feels safer.
It just feels, I don't dunno.
It's like having a nightlight,
you know, it feels like,
it feels like it's not too
far away from your front door,
whereas in the house, you're
kind of just there by yourself.
And we, we have a detached house as well.
So, so it feels like you're
just completely there isolated,
whereas in an apartment, you know,
there there's the apartment
block where there's people
outside sometimes going
in and out there's lights,
even at nighttime.
So I just, I dunno, right.
It just, it just feels like
you're a bit more isolated.
It feels scarier.
I could see why people can't
get scared of ghosts now in
Japan, Because this is creepy as.
- Oh yeah, definitely.
- I don't want to talk about cars. Yeah.
Like I've rinsed from the
comments last time they were like,
did you say, oh, when
I talked about garish,
people were very angry that I
spoke about. I was like, yeah.
But then it was just one of those.
That was another one of
those times. I was like,
I wish I could like go write a
script on why I don't believe
in ghosts and why that
stupid didn't come back.
- I don't.
- Believe in ghosts. There was a,
it was a guy who made like a,
he made a followup video
about us talking about cars,
basically, really
basically saying my point,
but eloquent and actually,
and actually explaining what
is this video called? It's by,
what's his name? Dark Viper.
I think you've watched
his trash tastes a lot.
He's a speed runner. And while
he was speed running games,
he was just giving us amazingly,
amazingly eloquent explanation
as to why people believe in
Garrison,
why it's generally like a
coping thing and whatnot.
And yeah. You know, it's stuff
that I normally agree with,
but it's one of those things
that you can never change.
If someone believes in ghosts,
you'd never going to
change their mind. Yeah.
Yeah.
But it's like, but for me to
be like, I don't believe in it.
Sometimes people get offended
by that because they've never
experienced it. Even if
I did, I wouldn't care.
But.
- The thing is I've never experienced it,
but I still believe in
it because it's, I dunno.
It's, it's cool.
- I understand that.
It's nice to believe in,
but it's just one of those
things that I'm just like,
maybe I'm just too boring. I don't know.
To me, it just doesn't make
sense to me, I believe.
- Yeah.
But that's,
I didn't believe until I
experienced something and then I
did believe it. So.
- Yeah. But again,
I always think there's a logical
explanation of everything.
I think there's,
there's always an explanation
that might be boring.
Might not be immediately
obvious that can explain it.
- Every,
every mystery ever in history
that's ever been solved as
turned out to be not magic. Right.
It's like.
- Yeah, there's always,
there's always something like,
we just don't have the
capability to understand certain
things. And yeah.
I guess the people use that
argument for, you can put that.
That could mean that we
don't ghost could be real.
And we don't understand
that. We're like, yeah.
But everything else in our world
thus far as is proven to be
the case, that stuff like
that doesn't tend to be wrong.
Yeah.
- I believe in like the
supernatural or the paranormal,
but I don't believe in 99% of
the media that comes out that
says like, here's.
- I think that I really despise,
and this is one thing that I
absolutely hate about and which
really leads me to feel strongly against.
It is the whole industry
that's propped up around no,
no exact ghost.
You know, I.
- Don't agree watching teller's spirit.
- Show predatory at times.
It makes me just want to
like, just get rid of it all.
Just yeah, no,
no one don't believe in
ghosts because if one person
believes in ghosts,
then there has to be someone
who then gets into believing
into ghost and then falls
down this whole rabbit hole.
Their husband dies. Someone
comes to him, tells me,
I'll let you speak to your
husband for $50 an hour.
- Yeah. That is, that
is, that is predatory.
That's predatory. And that's
like, that's kind of different.
That's just people taking
advantage of people who are like
very vulnerable and very
just looking for answers.
- But I believe there are
people out there who I wouldn't
class as vulnerable, but
maybe gullible more, sorry.
Oh, there's nothing bad happened to them.
There may be more likely to
believe this kind of stuff.
And I suppose you can't argue
that they're not getting what
they want. They're paying for some,
but that's kind of what in my
eyes is, but I guess to them,
well, maybe they'll ask
for, so I have friends,
very good friends who go to
fortune tellers and stuff.
And I just flat out just do
not believe fortune tellers.
- I don't believe.
- In that shady deal. I just,
you know, I think there is,
there are a lot of questions
that would be a raise. Oh.
So you know how to read
fortunes then why don't,
why are you not very fortunate?
It's why are you not using
this to your ability?
If you know, why.
- Do you not own about.
- 10 Points a Fortune's
able to be changed?
Is this something, you
know, and if not, why,
why has God bespoke bestowed
you with this knowledge of
people and.
- Why you're not using
it to your own advantage?
- I just find that there are
so many questionable actions
and ultimately it all comes
down to the fact that you're
charging money and you're
getting paid. Well.
- I said, you'll,
you'll free to believe
in whatever the you want,
as long as you don't
like extorting people.
- Yeah. I mean, when you, when you add,
when you add money into
the mix, of course,
it's going to get messy, especially,
especially if you try to like
monetize this. And I think.
- If you want to give away a
fortune for free, go ahead.
- No, but like, I, you know,
to like claim that you have
some kind of special power or
something,
but there's no way to prove
that it's there right now.
Whether you believe in ghosts or not,
there is no tangible proof
for, or against for me.
Like I believe, I believe
in the supernatural,
I believe in supernatural
things, because to me,
I believe that at the moment
there is so much about the
universe and the worlds
that even science context.
- I believe that I'm, I'm near certain,
that alien species out there
exists that we have not been
able to come across because
the university too big,
but like the whole concept of
modern ghosts and the way that
we understand them, I think
is completely incorrect.
- But what is the cons? What
is the concept of modern NGOs?
- Like the idea that someone would die
and they're just going to hang
around a place, haunting it.
Like, are you serious?
No, no, that's not good.
I believe in it. No, no, God, no.
- But it's also because like a
lot of like Shintoist belief,
revolver.
- Right? I understand that.
And that's why, that's why
I, you know, it's one of the,
it's very tough for me to argue again,
like I'm not prepared. I
think we got to talk about it.
I look at it enough, go watch this video.
This that's great. I don't know.
Like I, I just generally
am of a scientific mindset.
That's.
- I've I'm most of the time I
am generally favorable towards
the science soft science. It's not like,
I don't believe in like like
people who can read like star
signs and Gordian lines. I'm sure.
- Well, if you,
if you presented some kind of
panel activity that we had,
and we really sat down and we
really went through it and we
really started poking holes
in it, we could probably,
you know, debunk most things I'm sure.
And any of the stuff that is generally,
when you say it's unsolvable
or nothing to explain,
there's generally a massive
lack of information or not
enough stuff.
- But that's what I mean. Right?
It's like, it's, it's a lot like,
like UFO footage where it's
like, I believe in UFO's,
but I don't believe in 99% of the world's.
- Yeah, exactly.
Like a lot of the scandalous
stuff first, for sure.
Because we know that they exist.
There are tons of identities,
objects where they'd done married.
- But there are also a
lot of like, you know,
haunted videos and like
paranormal activity,
like videos and photos that are just like,
no matter how you look at it,
it's inexplainable becomes.
- Such a and I, I think.
- I feel like you just
hate the culture around it.
I really do.
Rather than I hate the culture.
I never talk about this.
Cause I'm just like, yeah.
I believe in ghosts on that.
Hardly mentioned it because
it's just like, I believe in it.
Cause I've seen it. I don't really like,
like to talk about it. Cause
it's just, it's my experience.
Right? It's just, it's just.
- You can't force
someone to believe in it.
- I don't want other
people to believe well,
like experience what I experienced.
That's just my experience with.
- It gets done personally,
but I will never be like,
you're a stupid person
for believing in that.
- And I'm not going to be like, how dare.
- You guys? You guys have some
form of some belief in it.
I would never be like,
I think you guys are stupid
because you believe in it.
I personally, to me it feels dumb.
Yeah. The idea of it.
- And I,
and I am completely fine with
people who don't believe in it
because you know, they can't be helped.
Right. It's like you
haven't experienced it.
Of course.
- Yeah. Cause like,
to me it's like the
opposite sense where yes, I,
and I completely agree
that culture is very messy.
It's very, very sensationalized,
which I hate sense.
You know? And I mean,
there's been so many,
like people who have debunked,
people who have monetized their staff,
how can you not know that
a lot of people are just
predatory, but at the same time,
I do believe there is a lot
of things that have not been
able to explain with current
science. And I think it's even,
I think,
I think it's naive to not think
that there is something not
something more out there that
hasn't been explained yet
because there's so many,
there's so much about, you know,
there's so much, we don't understand.
We take for granted because
science has science has evolved
and progressed so much that we
forget how much we still do.
Not understand.
- About.
- Just the unit.
- I guess like generally my,
my thought process along that
is if we don't understand the
situation and we don't have
the tools to get to explain it,
I don't think that a paranormal
explanation is the correct
one because you know, we didn't know.
We didn't know what caused
like cholera for a long time,
you know, I'm sure at some
point they thought it was,
it was the devil.
- Right?
- It's one of those
things where it's like,
generally when we've come to
at least my belief is that when
we,
we just don't have the tools
or the knowledge of subsequent
fields of physics or math to
understand certain things.
But also most of the time it's
so minuscule what happened.
It doesn't matter.
Like if your door closed one
night and it was real spooky,
it's like,
why would anyone delve deep
into trying to disprove you your
door uncomfortably close.
It's called a draft.
- Paranormal activity. Once I can see the.
- Pressure differential between
one of us, it's a thing.
But like there is so many
things that are so not worth
explaining generally,
most of the that is spooky is
so not worth wasting time on
trying to figure out because
it's so little information that
we have. Yeah.
It's not worth explaining
anyway. Well that's the problem.
Oh, sorry.
One more, one more time.
I also do want to acknowledge
that there is, you know,
the whole psychic stuff and all that.
I do understand that there
is a market that is pure
entertainment. Yeah.
Right. I could go to a fortune teller.
They could tell me a bunch of nonsense.
I don't believe what they said,
but it was fun to hear the
funny words and they tell me,
I understand that's an angle
and I'm fine with that.
I like your funny hoods magic magic, man.
Thank you for telling me
that I'm going to be wealthy.
I appreciate that.
But I'm also like going to here when I've,
I've I've gone to a fortune
teller before. Cause I like,
I like to experience what kind
of generic way they're going
to tell me about my future.
I love to understand the way
that they're trying to do it.
Yeah.
But that's not of a place of
me generally believing it.
But I do think that is kind of the bit,
there are a lot of people out
there who really believe in
this stuff. Yeah.
Yeah.
- I, I, I, my mom's one of
those people and I'm like,
I'm like sometimes a mum's
like tasted me to a fortune
teller and I'm like, mom,
again, I'm mom again,
do you get the same spiel.
- Every time? You know,
they say generic things that can apply.
- To anyone it's cold reading, cold,
cold reading is a technique
is a psychological technique.
But that's the thing.
- I have. I almost have an
appreciation for these psychics.
Not so much in the supernatural sense,
but more on the psychological sense of.
- Well, like Darren brown is more along.
I'm not, he always sees not psychic,
but like just using the
faults of the human.
- Psychology.
- Anyone who's good at that
would never claim to be psychic
or anything like that.
They understand that it's
a lot more than that.
Cause claiming the psychic
really undervalues what you're
doing.
Magic brain thing.
- Do I do I believe in like
psychics and people who can cold
read and stuff like that? No.
Do I believe there are people
out there who can maybe sense
some supernatural things? Yes I do.
Yeah, I do.
That's fair enough. I
mean, I mean, I think.
- Again, like gotten,
I have personal experience
of either ourselves.
- Th this comes from
just my understanding.
The brain is just so flawed
in many ways and that we,
you know, there's been like,
I know if someone gave an argument, this,
I saw a comment that
was arguing about this.
And it was just like, if you
can't prove it's, what's the,
what's the really horrible
argue method where it's like,
if you can't prove it's not
real than it than it Israel.
Yeah. And it's like, no, no, no, no, no.
You need the burden is
proving that it's real.
Not that it isn't.
- Real.
- This is what I find the most
annoying about arguing the
subject is that for some reason,
it's on the burden to me to
prove that you don't have
magical sixth sense. No.
Prove to me like concretely that you do.
- The people who say like, oh yes,
proof is a synonym for
truth. It's like, no, it's.
- Really not.
That's the thing. That's,
there's no way to pressure right now.
- And that's why it's
we call believing it.
But there's the so many things, right?
so many, like I'm trying.
- To argue a point here,
cut all your points here.
- There's just so many
clips of people. You know,
they go to people who are like, yeah,
I can talk to the dead
or I can feel the dead.
And then they showed them
pictures of people who aren't dead
the other two. And they're
like, Hey, they're not dead.
They're like, oh, well,
you know, it's like,
this happens so many times. So it's like,
at what point are we just
going to be like, come on.
This is just.
Literally everyone who
claims that they can do this
somewhere and other, when they
put the test that they fail,
like rarely, no one
ever passes these tests.
Why?
- But like most of the time, like most,
most of the people I've met
who have stories around this.
It's got nothing to do with
the sensationalized you see on
TV.
- But that's,
that's what also makes it
very difficult to have this
discussion.
People have their beliefs.
They're so strong in my beliefs
that they don't consider
that they could have maybe
experienced something that wasn't
that more often than not, they never.
- And it was like arguing about
someone with their religion.
Right. Which is like, you
never, like it's, it's just,
it's just a lose, lose argument.
Cause either you believe
in religion or you don't.
And according to the other
side, neither is right.
Or.
- And herbal admitting our own
faults as human being. Right.
There's so many, like, you
know, you go to criminal cases,
there's so many like trials
and stuff where my witness
testimony has been given and
they swear a hundred percent.
They have nothing to
lose by lying about this,
that they saw something happened
that turned out it didn't
happen.
And the memory because memory
is so unreliable and feelings
are so unreliable.
And what you see is never
exactly what you remember it to
be. This thing,
we are so terribly inconsistent
as humans that I find it
hard to believe that one person
who experienced sank. So,
so wildly kind of outer worldly
and that we don't remember.
- That's a worldly though. I
mean, there are big, there are,
there are bigger mysteries
out there in the world.
- It's case by case.
There are some times I've
heard stuff where I'm like, no,
and there's some things
I'm like, you know,
that just sounds like you had
an experience that I wouldn't
describe as like, that's
like a ghost thing.
It's like,
you just had an experience
that isn't like a ghost or
haunted.
You felt something. And I
felt that was a youth thing.
I don't think that was the
world, but you know what I mean?
I feel like that's us. That's like.
- The youth.
- As in, like,
I was in the same room with
you at the exact same time,
I would not have experienced
the same thing as you,
because it is entirely a thing
that is happening to you.
It's, it's, it's a mental
thing that's going on.
I don't think it's the thing
that's in this physical world
or this material world or whatever.
I think it's something that
if you put two people in the
same room and one of them is
having that kind of experience
and that you're things like when you,
when you went on that tour
or whatever, you know,
there's like, if you go on
a tour and you, you know,
haunted house and why one
person feel things in one desk,
I don't think it's a ghost
choosing, Ooh, spooky on God.
I it's. You are setting
your, your mind is capable.
You believe that that could happen.
You are a person who is subset
susceptible to feeling that
you could be haunted. So you
go into a place expecting,
maybe I could be haunted,
I'm open to this idea.
Something happens. You feel something.
And then you, your mind
is like haunted or.
- Well, I could argue with the,
I could argue the
complete opposite, right?
Because I would.
- Never, yeah, totally.
- Agree. No, no, because like you,
you are going to the mentality
that this susceptible to
believing in this thing, but
right on the opposite side of,
on the opposite side side of the fence,
you are someone who is so
adverse to this idea that you
would, you just shutting it out,
that you would shut out
whatever experience,
if there wasn't experience,
if there was right.
So.
- You never know you might've
perhaps experienced a similar
paranormal thing in your
head. It's just like, oh,
that just happened. That was a bit weird.
- Well, I brush it off possibly.
I think that it's, it's really
tough because like you said,
if it did happen, I,
I would probably just,
I would probably think of a
logical conclusion as to why
that happens more often than not.
I feel like I can adequately
explain what happened, where,
well, the people around me,
whether there was a noise
or something that happened,
I can normally be like.
- This whole, like, I guess,
culture to be interesting about.
Right. It's that like, we don't know,
like both sides don't know.
And it's the conversation of the believer.
Most of the non believer
who is right. Who the knows.
- I want to talk about. Yeah.
I think unfortunately there's
people who argue my side more
often than not argue the point
that people who believe the
are dumb. Yeah.
And so it kind of makes
this really horrible.
- Whole sensationalized.
- That's just, that's just
an image problem, right?
It is,
it is so much of an image
problem because so much of the
media around the supernatural
is like sensation. Especially,
especially like with like Halloween,
you like TV is unfucking,
watchable and Halloween because
everything is like ghost
specials, but that's why.
- Oh. That's what I like.
Even though I wasn't, I wasn't
saying like, you're stupid.
If you believe the.
The last time we still got this,
I got like the comments
people were saying to me,
there was some that were
like really rude about it.
They were like, Connor's just,
he just thinks everyone's
stupid. If they don't believe it,
I'm like, no, they didn't say that.
It's like, I personally, I
think that stuff to me is,
is dumb, but I would never be
like, you're a dumb person.
I believe.
- I think the important
thing is that you like people
recognize it is a belief and
people have experienced it as
some people can believe different things,
but you never want to make
them feel like they've been
discredited for reading.
- I think that's why we have
such a tough political climate
because for a long time,
all these really extreme
beliefs were like, no,
you're stupid.
- I think that's the
problem. As well as that,
there's really a difference
between people who have a belief
of like, this could be true.
And then the people who
swear that it's true.
And like, like I'm one of
those people mixed together.
And it's like, and that's
where like the bad image comes.
Like,
I'm definitely one of those
people who is the former where
it's like, I believe this
could be a possibility.
And I find it more fun personally
to think it in that sense,
but I'm not going to come
out and say like go surreal
hundred percent, no counter.
I mean, I'm not going to say that.
- You can't prove ghosts are not real,
but you can't prove go.
So.
- I have more enjoyment.
- I hate the argument. You can't.
- I personally have the
enjoyment of thinking,
you know what?
There is a possibility we just don't know.
And that's what I find exciting
about believing in this
thing.
- I mean, for me, it's like,
it's, it's less of just, it's,
it's less of just like,
this is a fun thing for me to believe.
And it's more of just like, you know,
everyone's had different experience.
I've had like my own experience
as well. And I couldn't,
I guess, like, I couldn't
logically explain it.
And so what happened was well at,
at this moment with my
experiences and what I've seen,
it's more likely for me that it exists,
then it doesn't exist.
And am I open to the fact
that maybe what I experienced
wasn't real and you know,
I'm open either way,
but right now, based on my
experience, I'm just like, yeah,
I believe it. And that's
the thing I believe.
Yeah.
- Okay. It's all about
whether, you know, cat facts,
no printer. It's all about,
I guess like whether you're
just like naturally susceptible
to, I guess like believing in
things like spirituality and.
- All that kind of stuff. It's
definitely is if you didn't.
- Grow up with that side, right.
- A little harder. Yeah.
It definitely comes to, I mean,
everyone around me was
quite religious Christian or
Catholic, et cetera, et cetera.
I just,
I think my probably probably
where I started to grow a
disdain towards that stuff is
I just didn't enjoy it when I
was younger. Like I hated church.
I had all that stuff. Right.
And then, you know,
when you get older and you've
discovered the internet,
you're like, oh, I can do my own research.
And then you start like Googling
stuff. And then I dunno,
I think.
- I was very.
- Yeah.
I think it's entirely reflective
of how I view the world.
Like I, you know, I guess like,
what's the meaning of life,
rock boy.
- Bro. You got to bring that out.
- Right now. Like why,
why, what are we, what is,
what is our purpose, man?
What are we doing? Rick
and Morty it's too deep.
- No, man.
It's just like.
- Oh, you know the same
reason why, when I look at it,
I look at a fish. What's
the, what's the fish doing?
What's the fish's purpose.
You know what.
- To get getting my stomach exactly.
- Be eaten by someone else. Right.
- So.
- So I sit here and I look
at like all these animals
that just there to be
eaten, no to survive.
And I think that in some
senses, we're just the same.
We're not, we're not, we don't
have some grand purpose to,
to have some spiritual
experience. It's just,
we're just here to, eat
and get on with our life.
If I want to play some league
of legends for 12 hours a day,
that the universe has allowed
me because I've done my duty,
which is survive.
And now I can mentally destroy
my life really. But you know,
I think once you've done, once
you've survived, that's it.
I believe.
- I believe they call that a nihilist.
- The problem is is that
now we just have, now,
now survival is just, the
rules have changed, man.
You used to being a Sigma
male man. It's hard.
They've got to pay bills. man.
- I can't be Sigma mail
while I pay the bills.
- Don't pay your bills.
Bills paid you.
Yeah, I've done it
because that's, you know,
I don't really believe there's a lot of,
a lot of going on in life.
I just kinda think that you
just kinda popped and you just,
just what you're doing. That's fine.
I wish that I could have some
more enjoyment out of it,
but that's just not how I
feel. I don't know why, man.
I wonder what made me feel that way. Well,
how do you guys feel about it?
It's just uncomfortable talking
about it. Yeah, yeah, sure.
- Yeah. I guess like, I don't
know, for me, it's like,
at least with like the whole
ghost thing for me is like,
obviously I had that story. I
told you guys about my sister.
- Do you feel like it reflects
your kind of spiritual?
I believe more.
I have a lot more respect
for spirituality than I do
religion. I think organized religion,
not too fond of the podcast
we're talking about.
- Like take,
we're taking on every topic
that you shouldn't be talking
about right now.
- No, I feel like for me
personally, it's like, again,
because I did grow up
in a, I mean like, yeah,
it was like the whole
Shintoist belief and you know,
used to go to temples all
the time and you know,
would hear stories about, you know,
my grandparents like being very, you know,
Shintoist and just believing in again,
like the whole spirituality
and like spirituality.
- Yeah.
I like something, you know,
I can get behind anything that
the general belief is a beat.
Good. And you all get good.
- When I was a kid, you know,
my grandma would tell me like,
you know, like don't throw
the rubbish in the river.
Not because it's bad for the pollution,
but because the river God is
going to get angry at you and
don't come back to bite you in
the. And I'm like, oh, well,
I don't want to angle them.
I'll do that.
It might be a little bit
of an OSS back was legit.
But you know,
as a kid like that is I think
a healthy way to like look at
a logical.
- Let's get behind anything,
but it's generally just be
a nice person. That's like,
just give back. Yeah.
That's like, I feel like I'm,
I want to do that just myself.
I don't need some kind of a
belief system for me to do that.
I just want to be a good person
and do that because I want
to give back.
- I'm not walking around
as a 27 year old going, oh.
I've been in an angle.
Like at the back of my mind,
there is a pot where it's,
you know,
it builds like not only respect
for surroundings around you,
but also just becoming a
better person. And it's like,
you do what you have to believe in.
As long as you're not hurting
anyone else believe what you
have to believe in to be a better post.
- No, because like my
experience was, you know,
obviously I was raised up to
be a Buddhist and everything
like that and in my life. Yeah.
I mean, okay.
So I was so here's his,
here's a bit more behind
that backstory. Right?
So I was a monk when I was like, yeah.
- Write it down, write it down.
- So as I said before, I was
among two times in my life.
One time I was a kid,
one time it was an adult.
So the kid thing was basically
doing it. So I could like,
you know,
give good karma to my family
because that's just how the
that's just how I was raised. You know.
- There's two Jensey.
I thought you were on
about Reddit then for.
- Funnily enough karma was
the concept that existed
So, so then I, you know,
so then after that I went to university,
grew up in everything and
then I had this, I had this,
you know, spiritual
experience with, with, with,
with some people. And then
after having that experience,
I kind of just like,
I don't know what the right
word or the right term to like
coin the SAS,
but I just kind of realized
that I didn't know what the I
believed. Right.
Because, because,
because I had this experience
that I couldn't explain
logically, and I was
like an engineer before,
so I'm like everything scientific,
everything can be explained
logically had this experience.
And then I kind of
realized, what do I believe?
And then there's one.
And then at that point I realized
everything that I believed
wasn't because I actually believed it.
But it was just because that
was what I was raised to be.
- Yeah. That's,
that's one thing that's really
difficult because I mean,
you have to be raised,
will be raised by wolves.
So it's kind of hard to get
an unbiased view of like a
religion or spirituality,
because you often have so much
baggage or kind of backstory
that kind of thing. So it's
often hard to look at it.
- Yeah. So like that,
that was like actually a huge
turning point in my life that
like basically pull my
Clate Sleen put me like,
put me on a clean slate.
And I was like, okay,
I'm going to become a monk
now that, and that was like,
that was like the actual
point when I'm like,
I'm going to become a monk.
Not because my parents told me to,
but because I need to like
figure this out myself and figure
out is this what I
actually believe? Or is it,
or is it something that was
instilled to me as a kid?
And so that was like,
that was like the big
decision maker to be like,
I'm going to start
something new in my life.
I'm going to like try to
experience this lifestyle.
Not because not because anyone told me to,
but because I chose this,
I chose to experience this
and whatever comes out of this
experience and whatever comes
out of these beliefs are my
own.
That's why right now I, you
know, so I became a monk.
When,
when you were alone by yourself
with your thoughts for, for,
for four weeks or a month,
two months, you have,
you have a lot of time
to think about, right?
Yeah. And so in these, in
these like two months, you bet,
I basically had just like had
time to rewind my entire life
and basically break down why
I believe the things I do and
why I'm the person I am. And
like, after becoming a mom can,
after having that time to
myself and, you know, studying,
you know, I already knew
about, you know, Buddhist,
the British religion and the
Buddhist beliefs and the,
and so I, after that, I
knew what I believed out of.
Let's say, what's the
traditional religion teaches you.
But I also had my own beliefs
and my own views on top of
that.
- It should be there. I think that's,
you should take the calls of
something like a structure that
you have a spirit or whatever you like,
and then just kind of add your
own of things that you really
want to Japan.
- Is pretty.
- Notorious for that. Right?
- It's like, yeah, this.
- Is what we believe the whole thing
with like calmer as well.
Like I, I almost in like a scientific way.
I think that if, you
know, if, if generally,
if you're a good, you know,
you're a positive impact
on people. I think just,
it just comes back like every.
- Reaction as an
Do I believe there's this cosmic system?
- I don't have to think so.
I can just go and do whatever
the I want it, but yeah,
it's got the soup kitchen.
- The kitchen.
But do I believe in, like in general,
if you're a good person that
it will come back to you a
hundred percent? I believe, I
truly believe that I'm like,
that's that I guess is the biggest thing.
The biggest change before, like,
before me just being told what
to believe and actually like
deciding what I believe it's
like once you decided it,
or once I decided that
nothing can change my opinion,
because I was like,
I'm so like set in my beliefs
because this is basically
everything that I've built
from my entire experience of
life.
And the only thing that can
change this is new things I
experienced. Because like,
because that, and to me,
that's why I guess nothing
really phases me when it comes to
like, arguing about my
beliefs, like my core beliefs,
because I'm I'm so I'm very set in it.
- I feel like I have anything
controversial either.
I've just got to be good. I
mean, like you say, you, like,
you had all this whole
experience, but I mean,
ultimately we, we came to
the same conclusion right.
Through our own means. Right.
I think that's what it's
about. I don't know.
I don't have a problem with
how however you want to do your
life. Just don't.
Yeah. Don't be a negative impact.
- Again,
you're free to believe whatever
the you believe just don't
like hurt or inconvenience others. Yeah.
Like what,
what me off is when people would
try to put their beliefs on
other people.
Like I have my core beliefs
and I firmly believed them,
but I would never try to say,
Hey, this is my experience.
And you should experience
and believe exactly the same
things as me. Because,
because to me, you can't,
you can't force that upon
someone, you know, you can,
you can raise a kid,
but I hope my kid goes to the
exact same thing that I went
through when they realized,
I know I need to like,
decide the for myself.
I'm sure there's a lot
of people watching this.
I've never thought about that
this deeply. And you know,
that's,
that's not exactly a bad thing
because it's something that I
never had to think about until
I had some experience that
forced me to like, put myself,
put me in this position.
- Oh, there's nothing.
You can just go your whole
life. And you've been,
you've been raised to believe
a certain thing and you just
never questioned it. Yeah.
That's what I always
found quiet. Like, oh,
cause I always always questioning
everything from like the
get-go like anything they told
me, I was like, nah, I to,
you know, which is strange.
Cause I T I guess that's why
I'm so adverse to stuff like
that. Because ever since a young age,
I can remember I was the
annoying kid who was like, no,
I don't, I don't think that's right.
But that's just, cause
I didn't know how I,
I didn't know why I got that mindset from,
but I've always been like that.
- This is some people just
don't really question things
because they just think, oh,
if I just follow what
everyone else believes,
and if I just follow the crowd,
then nothing can go wrong.
Right. So you're.
- Telling me I'm a Sigma man.
I'm saying that you're a.
- Lead a Sigma.
You're a leader in your own mind.
- Right.
- I just think some people
just have never thought that deeply
about it. And that's fine.
There's a lot of people I've met.
There's a lot of people I've
met who are just happy and
they've, they've never
like they've honestly,
I wish I was more like that
because my God likes some people.
- Existential crisis in the bathtub.
- Members of the church of
the flying spaghetti monster.
Like what happy dude, we got
spaghetti most thrown outside.
- Yeah. For me, for me, I just think just,
don't try to put your
beliefs on other people.
Try to accept what anyone else believes.
Even if it's like different from yours,
you can believe what the you want.
You can like if people want
to hear about your experiences
and give you the
opportunity, then go ahead,
tell your experiences, tell your beliefs.
But if, if, if they're not interested,
which a lot of people are
not going to be interested,
then just give them that don't
get offended and don't get
offended and don't get offended
when they believe something
different as well. He understood.
- That whole aspect of it
getting really angry about other
people's.
- Well like being like how
dare you don't believe the same
thing I believe in.
I ain't never got that either.
It just seems very like, I dunno.
It's like very like,
like self concerned about
like feeding animals and like
that. It's like.
- I just want people to be
comfortable. So I'm like,
I guess if you have a
dietary requirement. Yeah.
It's not a big deal.
It was like one meal of my life
that we won't be able to eat
pork. I think, I think I'll be all right.
Like I'm not offended.
It's fine. I'm good.
I'll I'll you know, and even
then it's like, it's, it's,
it's, it's kind of strange.
I don't know.
- Steve to I'll go in a bit of
a lighter topic, but before.
- Where's the poop. There's not
enough poop in this episode.
I just.
- Shipped myself.
- So I've been addicted to
like a new type of video
reasonably.
- I know you tweeted about.
- Yeah. You're just like,
it's like sometimes,
sometimes the YouTube algorithm
just works in mysterious
ways.
- You know what,
you know what sent a story
that starts off with that
sentence? Isn't going to lead to anything.
- Yeah. So like, so like grandiose.
So like I, I get this video
recommended on my YouTube,
which is like, oh,
I watched someone sharing
cow hooves and like,
they get instant relief from bubbles.
It's like, what's the?
What, what is, what is,
what is YouTube thinking?
We'd be interested in.
- I have that section of like
videos that I never subscribe
full,
but a pleasantly surprising
when I watched them stuff like
restoration cleaning cars. Yeah.
There was one that was
like testing mouse traps.
And this guy worked on a farm
and he just had like every
single mouse trap.
Yeah. And it was just like, weirdly,
like weirdly like kinda like, oh,
that's cool how the trap works.
So I'm watching my style.
So I of feel bad.
- I feel,
I feel the same way about like
guys who want to link massive
ant farms and stuff like that.
- Like.
- That makes me so anxious.
- Like, like I want one, up.
And like, you're just,
it's just ants everywhere.
- Just to say, I mean, he, he
doesn't have to invite people,
whatever.
I think he gets out of having
to have the friends over
by you, but I've got the end phone.
- Yeah. I remember just
watching the Calhoun videos
and I was,
I've never been, I've never
seen something that I've been,
that is like disgusting, but
weirdly relaxing as well.
It's it's.
- This it's because that comes off so.
- Clean, it comes off so clean
and just, it's kinda like,
you know, it's,
it's kinda like scratching
an H or something like that.
Whereas.
- Videos. I don't.
- Like seeing the,
seeing the pus come out
of like the cowl hooves.
It's like disgusting. But like,
for some, for some reason,
when you see the words,
instant relief in the title,
you're just like, I'm
happy for the cow man.
I'm, I'm happy.
Something about instant relief.
And the title is just like,
I feel better. I feel better for the cow.
It's disgusting.
- We used to just do with cows. If we did,
wouldn't doing this,
they just like chilling.
Just would that look
disgusting? Terrorists.
- Just know, standing out in the paddock,
just chewing grass being like, well,
I'm an insufferable pain right
now, but you know, what am I.
- Yeah.
Evolution.
- Kind of up. Then I feed them.
Just collect.
Unable to clean them.
- Yeah.
Because like these cattle hooves
are like hard because what
they have to do, you use to share them.
It's like raise a shop
and they can like barely,
barely get through them.
So how the these cows can
survive without humans is just
beyond me. Cause I've seen
some of the cow videos.
- Put them in like cages.
- Well maybe the reason
why, like, you know,
when cows tip over and they can't get up,
it's not because they can't
get it just because they.
- Don't want it.
They're like, oh, Jesus.
Cause like I imagine it it's
just like the worst ingrown
toenail you've ever had,
but you don't have anything to cut it.
And like I've, I've had some
pretty bad ingrown toenails.
So I feel some kind of
spiritual connection to the cow.
Just seeing this pus
come out right. If God.
- And make a video like that,
he put like instant relief.
Hashtag relatable.
If it's relatable. Yeah.
- The me using a toilet
instantly satisfying.
- 30 Minute compilation.
You're using different.
- Per days.
Instant.
- Relief for J complex.
Relatable. This place is very special.
I went to a restaurant. I
did want to vote it down.
One star. The toilet had an every day.
It was a really nice restaurant.
They'd never seen it.
I was like, what the?
What the got to go good at my
meal after I've just wiped my.
Like an animal disgusting.
- Well maybe they expected you
to like finish the meal first.
Going.
- Back to It's not.
It's not. It's.
- Literally, literally one week later.
- It's not it's per days. And I love them.
- Only on trash day. Spirituality.
- I want to be de installed
in every chair in my house.
- When are we getting Toto
sponsored trash tastes.
- I ain't got to go to the
turtle museum or whatever. Toto,
can you spot? I want to go.
We should do it the day. The day.
Like writing challenge.
- Yeah.
I'll be down for that, man.
I'll be down for that.
- That's so bad. I don't know.
It depends on you. Cause you know,
cause some people like different
strengths and stuff and
some machines can't quite get
the strength. Yeah, exactly.
- Well, so it was like,
how accurate is that?
First? Is that first?
That first strike.
- Yeah.
The water is too cold. Yeah.
Heat out the right time.
- Anyway. That's for a future
episode of trash taste,
I guess for trash.
- Taste. You know who else likes?
Today's our patrons. They.
- Wish they could have
installed in every house.
- We might get a Toto, trash
tastes, collab of light.
Some trash tastes for days. But all.
- These patrons who believe in.
- Well maybe don't believe
well, maybe done it matter.
Yeah.
- This guy might not believe he.
- Goes, yeah, this guy might.
- No. What next tier is
fortune telling or deciders.
We'll send you a message.
How.
- Can you do it?
- Can we do it? Can we.
- Do a Meridian, generic
one out to everyone.
Can we.
- Do them already in line to
your list of which ones are
believable? Which ones I'm.
- Done. I'm done.
This episode is finished.
- If you enjoyed the show,
make sure to subscribe to our
Patrion patron.com/trash days.
Also false on subreddit or
send us your names on the cyber
false on Twitter. And
if you head our face,
listen to us on Spotify. I
that up first time losing it.
I'm losing it. All right, bye.